GOOD
MORNING. WE'RE CALLING TO ORDER
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SIX
HEARING ON THE REMAINING BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS ALL WITH A TO
WELCOME EVERYBODY TO THE LAST
BUDGET SUB SIX HEARING OF THE
YEAR THIS IS LET ME JUST
REITERATE TO THE PUBLIC THEY'VE
HEARD THIS BEFORE TO THE PUBLIC
IN ROOM. FORTY TWO OH TWO WE
ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT
IN PERSON HEARING EVEN THOUGH
THIS IS THE LARGEST ROOM IN THE
CAPITOL WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
SO MANY MEMBERS- WHEN THE
MEMBERS DO COME YOU'LL SEE THAT
WE ARE SUBSCRIBING TO PHYSICAL
DISMISSING PROTOCOLS. WE ARE
ASKING FOR THE PUBLIC AS
INTERIM LEAVE TO RESPECT THOSE
PROTOCOLS AND TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT APPROPRIATE TIME AND
THEN ONCE THEY'VE MADE THAT
COMMENT IF THEY COULD PLEASE
EXIT EXIT THE ROOM HOW WE
ALLOWING ONE MINUTE. PER PERSON
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT- WE HAVE
PANELISTS WITH PUBLIC FINANCES
WHILE THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WE'VE ASKED THE L. A.
O. TO PRESENT THE BILLS AND FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
COMMENT ON EACH OF THEM. I WILL
GO THROUGH EACH OF THE BILLS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AS
WELL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THEN ALLOW TIME FOR QUESTIONS
WE AGAIN WILL NOT BE VOTING
TODAY AND AFTER. THE MEMBER
QUESTIONS WE WILL AFTER ALL THE
BILLS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED WE
WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
AGAIN E HAVE A MODERATED PHONE
LINE- THE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AS WELL AS THE
ACCESS CODE IS A THREE. FIVE
FOUR TWO OH TWO WE ARE ALSO WE
HAD A INDIVIDUAL WHO HAD PRE
RECORDED- PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE
WILL NOT BE ACCEPTING THOSE
TODAY WE ASK IF YOU DO HAVE PRE
RECORDED PUBLIC COVER IF YOU
COULD PLEASE EMAIL THAT TO THE
COMMITTEE. ARE YOU CAN EMAIL
THAT AS WELL AS ANY. ANY
WRITTEN PUBLIC COMMENT TO THE
WORD OF BUDGET SUB S. U. B. SIX
THE NUMBER SIX AT ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV. IF ANY ISSUE GETTING
INTO THE PHONE LINE PLEASE CALL
OUR COMMITTEE NUMBER NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE NINE OR FEEL FREE TO. GO
TO OUR WEBSITE IF YOU JUST
GOOGLE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SIX YOU CAN
GET THE INFORMATION. SO TODAY
ALL WE ARE CONSIDERING EIGHT
BILLS. THESE ARE FOLLOW UP
ITEMS FROM THE THREE. THE PARTY
DEAL IN JUNE MANY OF THESE
BILLS WE JUST HEARD A FEW DAYS
AGO- WE ARE RE HEARING THEM
BECAUSE- THEY HAVE BEEN
AMENDED- MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN
YOU KNOW JUST MINOR AMENDMENTS
SO WE DO ASK THE PUBLIC TO.
PLEASE OF PLEASE MAKE COMMENTS-
REGARDING THOSE BILLS TO
POTENTIALLY ANY THE CHANGES.
SINCE THIS IS OUR LAST HEARING
DURING THIS VERY UNUSUAL
PANDEMIC YEAR LET ME JUST START
OFF BY TAKING OUR ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS WERE HERE IN THE ROOM
WITH US THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE.
ASSEMBLY TV THE RULES COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS THE LEGISLATIVE DATA
CENTER AND LEAD COUNSEL- IT WAS
QUITE A HERCULEAN FEAT I THINK
IF YOU HAD TALKED TO US IN
APRIL WHEN WE WERE. ON
RECESSING WE HAD TO TIME
IMAGINE. WHETHER WE'D BE ABLE
TO HOLD IN PERSON HEARINGS OR
HOW WE'D BE ABLE TO DO THAT HOW
WOULD BE ABLE TO INVOLVE THE
PUBLIC- AND I KNOW THAT WE'VE
HAD SOME UPS AND DOWNS OF THE
HEARINGS ARE REALLY ASK- IN
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
AND RESPECT. FOR THE PROFIT THE
WE'VE DONE OUR BEST TO TRY TO
INCORPORATE ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AT THE SAME TIME
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN KEEP-
THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM WHO ARE
PHYSICALLY HERE SAFE. AND WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF BEING ABLE TO
HAVE DONE THAT SO FAR ALSO
WANTED TO THANK THE L. A. O.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
AS MY BUDGET STAFF FOR THAT
HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS OF
WORK TO. CRAFT THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET AND ALSO GET THE LAST
FINAL A BILL THROGH- THIS YEAR
HAS BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO BE IN OFFICE
TOGETHER WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO PHYSICALLY BE A ROOSTER. AND
WORKING REMOTELY AS WE ALL KNOW
IS SIGNIFICANTLY LESS EFFICIENT
FROM FROM OUR OFFICES
STANDPOINT AND BEING IN PERSON-SO IT'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE. SO BOB LET ME STOP
THERE AND TO SEE IF MY VICE
CHAIR. WOULD MIDDLE MICHAEL TO
MY BECAUSE WE LAST THE LAST
WITH HIS LIFE BUT IS WHAT WE-
IS ALWAYS ONE MORE HUMAN BUT I
THOUGHT OPENED. OPEN COMING UP
TO MY VOICE. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK FOR CAN. THIS YOU
KNOW IT'S INTERESTING I CAN'T
FEEL. TWO DIFFERENT WAYS ABOUT
THE HEARING OR AVING TO BE ON
THE ONE HAND I'M GRATEFUL THAT
WHEN BILLS ARE SUBS.
SUBSTANTIVELY AMENDED. THAT WE
TAKE THE TIME. AND DEMONSTRATE
THE TRANSPARENCY TO HEAR THOSE
BILLS AGAIN AND COMMITTEE.
BEFORE THEY GO TO THE FLOOR. ON
THE OTHER HAND TODAY I AM
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED BECAUSE
THREE OF THE BILLS THAT WERE.
AND I JUST CAME INTO. ON
FRIDAY. AND THIS IS THE FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO RECEIVE BEFORE THEY'RE
VOTED ON. ONE DAY BEFORE THE
END OF SESSION WHICH IS
TOMORROW. THESE ARTISTS VERY
SUBSTANTIVE POLICY BILLS FIRST
OF ALL THEY HAVE NO PLACE
BEING. HEARD IN A BUDGET
COMMITTEE THEY SHOULD BE BUDGET
BILLS AT ALL. AND SECOND OF
ALL. I THINK TRANSPARENCY. AND
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY DEMANDS
THAT. WHEN WE DISCUSS SOMETHING
SO SUBSTANTIVE THAT WE GIVE. A
LITTLE BIT. MORE TIME FOR THE
PUBLIC TO WEIGH IN AND COMMENT
AND- GIVE OURSELVES A BIT MORE
TIME T BE DELIVERED ABOUT THIS
SO I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED ABOUT
THAT WE'LL ALL TALK. ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC BILLS AS WE MOVE
THROUGH BUT- I JUST DIDN'T FEEL
LIKE. I COULD- I COULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY GO BY WITHOUT
SAYING THAT. GREAT THANK YOU
MISPRICED OR ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS BEFORE WE
START. OKAY PERFECT SO LET'S
START ON TO THE FIRST BILL
WHICH IS GOING TO BE S. B. ONE
FIFTEEN- WHICH IS OUR- BUDGET
BILLS JUNIOR. THE RESTAURANT
LOL. GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
MR CHEN NUMBERS- THIS IS BRIAN
BROWN WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- SO SB ONE
FIFTEEN IS HE SAID IS. INCLUDE
REVISIONS TO THE- TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET BILL YOU HEARD THIS
BILL LAST WEEK BUT THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
SINCE THEN ALL HIGHLIGHT THE
MAIN ONES IN THAT WERE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. OFFERED IN THE AREA
OF NATURAL RESOURCES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT SB ONE FIFTEEN
PROVIDES A LOAN FROM THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP FIND THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND TO SUPPORT THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM. THE AMOUNT OF
THE LOAN CAN BE UP TO A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS UNDER
THE BILL AND IS INTENDED TO
BACK FILL ANY CAP AND TRADE
AUCTION REVENUES TO ACCEPT THAT
THEY FALL SHORT OF THE DESIRED
PROGRAM LEVEL- IN ADDITION-
THERE THE BILL INCLUDES
INCREASED APPROPRIATION FROM
VARIOUS NATURAL RESOURCES BONDS.
THE PROPOSITIONS ONE AND SIXTY
EIGHT PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL
ONE HUNDRED TEN MILLION OR SO-
FOR HABITAT RESTORATION FLOOD
PROTECTION AND OTHER PROJECTS.
IN OTHER AREAS SB ONE FIFTEEN
PROVIDES THIRTY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION TO THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AT
THIS IS TO EDUCATE WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS ABOUT COOKING
NINETEEN WORKPLACE HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES WORKERS
COMPENSATION PAID SICK LEAVE
AND ANTI RETALIATION
PROTECTIONS. IT PROVIDES THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR KOBE NINETEEN AWARENESS
COMMUNITY OUTREACH EFFORT. IT
ALSO PROVIDES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- ALLOWS THEM TO
TRANSFER ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESS HIRING CREDIT WHICH IS
UNDER CONSIDERATION AND PART OF
SB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. LASTLY
I'LL NOTE THAT THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF SB ONE FIFTEEN HEARD
BY THE COMMITTEE INCLUDED SOME
PROVISIONS REGARDING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LONG TERM CARE
HOME PROPOSAL. HOWEVER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF- HAD
RESCINDED THAT PROPOSAL AND
THEREFORE THE BILL HAS REMOVED
A RELATED PROVISIONS WITHOUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. GREAT
THANK YOU TO PERFORMANCE. AS
THE FINANCE. I GUESS WOULD HELP
OF MEAT I APOLOGIZE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE COULD ACT GOOD
MORNING LISA BRZEZINSKI THE
DEPARTMENT- IN A FINANCE I
DON'T HAVE TOO MUCH TO ADD TO
THE ALIENS COMMENTS I THINK
THEY DID A VERY GOOD JOB OF
SUMMARIZING THE NEW AMENDMENTS
ADDED TO THIS BILL. HOWEVER I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THE
MAJORITY OF THE MINUTES AND THE
STILL DO REFLECT TECHNICAL
CLEANUP AND CONFORMING CHANGES-
HOWEVER THIS BILL DOESN'T
INCLUDE ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND-
APPROPRIATE. AND ALSO INCLUDE
SOME NON TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT MANY OF THESE
APPROPRIATIONS AND NON
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS. ARE
INTENDED TO ASSIST THE STATE.
IN OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
THE IMPACT OF THE CODE NINETEEN
RECOVERY- ALSO. AS FOR INSTANCE
THERE IS AN EFFORT AND AID IN
AN EFFORT IN EIGHT TO PROMOTE
THIS AT ECONOMIC STIMULUS THIS
BILL CONTAINS A PACKAGE OF
AMENDMENTS. THE NEXT AVAILABLE
OVER TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN VARIOUS
BONDS. WHICH WILL ALLOW FOR
ACCELERATION OF SPECIFIC RELATE
PROJECTS. SO WITH THAT. I WOULD
LIKE UNANIMOUS A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ARE HERE AND
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE ON.
THESE ISSUES. THANK YOU. TAKING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY I'M NOT SEEING
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WITH
KEEP GOING. LET'S GO TO S. B.
EIGHT ONE FIVE WHICH IS THE
GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CAROLYN
CHIU FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AS A CHARITY
MENTIONED SB EIGHT FIFTEEN IS
THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT CLEAN UP
BILL- RELATIVE TO- THE BILL
THAT WAS HEARD AND- THIS
COMMITTEE A FEW DAYS AGO THERE
ARE A FEW CHANGES ALL NOTE- ONE
OF THE MORE SIGNIFICANT ONES.
ARE SPECIFICALLY SB EIGHT
FIFTEEN WOULD MAKE
CLARIFICATIONS TO THE
ENFORCEMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PROVISIONS CONTAINED
WITHIN AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE ESTABLISH A STREAMLINED
PROCESS FOR APPROVING
FARMWORKER HOUSING AND
PROHIBITED THE USE OF STATE
FUNDING FOR FARMWORKERS WITH H.
TWO A. VISAS. THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY THE VARIOUS STATE
HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR MIGRANT
FARM WORKERS IS PROHIBITED FROM
BEING RENTED SOLD OR SUBLEASED
TO AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYERS WHO
EMPLOY WORKERS WITH H. TWO A.
VISAS. BUT THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THESE PROVISIONS OR OTHER
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL. THANK
YOU FINANCE. MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- NO FURTHER QUESTIONS I
HEARD EXCUSE ME NO FURTHER
COMMENTS ON. ON THIS BILL BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
HAVE COLLEAGUES HERE TO ASSIST
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY. MEMBERS MISTER COOPER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LESS
TROUBLE TO YES ON AB SEVENTY
THREE BECAUSE THE GOAL OF THE
US PROVIDE MORE HOUSING THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITTED INCREASING
STATE SUPPORT OF HOUSING
HOWEVER THIS BILL SEEMS TO BE
GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION BY
STATING THAT IMP THAT ANY
EMPLOYER WHO HIRES EVEN ONE H.
TWO EMPLOYEE CANNOT UTILIZE ANY
HOUSING THE SUBSIDIZED BY THE
STATE. MIAC EMPLOYERS HAVE BOTH
H. TWO A. AND NOT H. TWO
EMPLOYEES OF THIS BILL ALSO
PROHIBIT THOSE NON H. TWO
EMPLOYEES FROM UTILIZING
EMPLOYER PROVIDED HOUSING THE
SUBSIDIZED BY THE STATE. TO
PROVIDE INSURANCE OF. MISTER
COOPER DANIELLE BRENDA CAN YOU
PLEASE REPEAT YOUR QUESTION
WITH THIS BILL ALSO PROHIBIT
THOSE NON H. TWO EMPLOYEES FROM
UTILIZING EMPLOYER PROVIDED
HOUSING THAT IS SUBSIDIZED BY
THE STATE. THIS DANIEL BRANDON
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
EMPLOYEE HAS THE PROGRAM
OVERSEES THE PROVISIONS
EMPLOYEE HOUSING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF THE
PLACE IMMIGRATION STATUS. THE
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY EACH CD
IN CONJUNCTION WITH LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES- THE
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS STATE
FUNDED HOUSING PROGRAMS RE USED
FOR H. TWO A. EMPLOYEES THE
PROPOSAL ALLOWS EMPLOYEES TO
ACCESS ANY HOUSING THAT IS
FUNDED BY THE STATE. HOWEVER
EACH TO A EMPLOYERS CANNOT
RENTS HOUSING SUBSIDIZED BY THE
STATE AS WAS THE INTENT OF AB
AT SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE. THE
GOAL OF SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
TO CHANGE THAT AND BUILD MORE
HOUSING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITTED TO INCREASING THE
FUNDING. PROVIDING A CERTAIN
HOUSING COULD NOT BE PROVIDED.
TO GUEST AG WORKERS AND MY
QUESTION IS THE UNRUH CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT SPECIFICALLY
PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION IN
HOUSING. BASED ON IMMIGRATION
STATUS I APPRECIATE THIS
TRAILER BILL IS INTENDED TO FIX
THAT PROBLEM IN AB SEVENTY
THREE. SO I NEED TO ASK. DOES
THIS TRAILER BILL ALLOW FOR
EACH TO EMPLOYEES TO UTILIZE
HOUSING THAT IS BUILT WITH
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE. IN THIS PAPER DANIEL
BRAND WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE PROPOSAL ALLOWS
EMPLOYEES TO ACCESS ANY HOUSING
THAT IS FUNDED BY THE STATE IT
DOESN'T ALLOW EACH TO A
EMPLOYERS TO ACCESS HOUSING
FUNDED BY THE STATE. SO I'M
CONCERNED THIS BILL MAY HINDER
ACCESS FOR SOME EMPLOYEES TO
THE STATE'S HOUSING FOR THE
HARVEST PROGRAM. OFFERING
TEMPORARY HOTEL HOUSING TO
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS WHO NEED
TO ISOLATE DUE TO COVE IN
NINETEEN. THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS THIS NEWLY
LAUNCHED PROGRAM. TO ASSIST
COVER NINETEEN POSITIVE OR
EXPOSE WORKERS BY PROVIDING
THEM HOUSING TO SELF ISOLATE.
ACCORDING TO THE STATE THE SEAL
THE COVER NINETEEN WEBSITE. THE
STATE IS INTRICATELY INVOLVED
IN COORDINATING. THE BOOKING OF
HOUSING FOR THE HARVEST HOTEL
ROOMS. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES.THIS IS
DIFFERENT FROM COUNTYTO COUNTY
BUT THIS SEEMS TO BE FUNDED
WITH A MIX OF FEDERAL FUNDS.
COUNTY FUNDS. IN NONPROFIT
FUNDS WHICH MAY INCLUDE STATE
FUNDING AND AGAN PLAYER FUNDING
AS WELL. SO I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW. WITH THE POLICIES
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL
POTENTIALLY DENY SUCH CRUCIAL
HOUSING TO CERTAIN EMPLOYEES.
BASED ON IMMIGRATION STATUS
BECAUSE YOU STAYED FUNDS TO
HOUSE H. TWO EMPLOYEES IS NOT
ALLOWED. NO SIR. OKAY THANK YOU.
MISTER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'D LIKE TO JOIN MR COOPER IN
EXPRESSING SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS RECENTLY- ADDED PROVISION
REGARDING H. TO A HOUSING
INDUSTRY LOWER BILL. SO AT MY
QUESTION IS TWO FOLD FIRST OF
ALL- WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING THIS LANGUAGE. DARWINIST
AND WHAT IT'S- WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IT AND
THE SECOND QUESTION IS. WHAT IS
SO URGENT ABOUT THIS THAT IT
NEEDED TO BE ADDED INTO THIS
TRAILER BILL THE DAY BEFORE THE
END OF THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
THANK YOU DANIEL BRANDON I'M
FIRST AT. A FOR FINANCE I THINK
YOU'RE A MEMBER. FIREWOOD FIRST
NOTE THAT THIS TRAILER BILL WAS
FIRST PRESENTED IN FEBRUARY
WITH ABOUT 90% OF THE TIME-
CONTENT REMAINING THE SAME THE
CHANGES ENSURE THAT KNOWING
IMMIGRATION RECORDS ARE
REQUESTED AS A MEANS OF MEETING
A REQUIREMENT. TO NOT ALLOW
STATE FUNDED HOUSING TO BE USED
TO HOUSE H. TWO A. EMPLOYEES.
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS THIS FOR
ANY HOUSING FUNDED AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TO
DATE IN A NEWLY CONSTRUCTED
HOUSING IS AN FUNDED THAT IS
AFFECTED BY THIS DEPARTMENT. I
WOULD NOTE THAT. HELLO PARDON
ME. UNDER WITHOUT THIS LANGUAGE
H. H. CITY WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ENSURING THAT NO H. TWO A.
WORKERS LIVE IN ANY HOUSING
PROJECT IN WHICH EACH CD FUNDS
ARE INVESTED. TO ENSURE THIS H.
THE WOULD HAVE TO COMPLETE A
TENANT FILE CHECK OF NON EACH
CITY UNITS. THIS PROPOSAL
NARROWS THE SCOPE REQUIRING
EACH CITY TO ONLY INSPECT UNITS
FOR WHICH IT PROVIDED FUNDING
WITHOUT THIS PROPOSALS THE COST
TO IMPLEMENT AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WOULD XCEED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. AND NINE MILLION ANNUALLY
ONGOING. THAT IS WHY WE BELIEVE
IT'S NEEDED NOW. OKAY AND I
DON'T. I DON'T A BELIEVER THE
POINT BUT IF YOU BELIEVED IT
WAS NEEDED ON FRIDAY WHY DIDN'T
THE BILL THAT WE HEARD LAST
WEEK HAVE THE AND IT. IS MY
QUICKNESS RHETORICAL YOU DON'T
NEED TO ANSWER BUT THE BUT I
MEAN YOU SEE THE POINT HI THIS
IS A SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
CAUSED. SUBSTANTIAL CONCERNS
FROM THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
IN THE STATE AND I THINK IT
DESERVES A FAIR HEARING AND A
BALANCED- LEGISLATIVE EFFORT TO
DETERMINE THAT THE NEEDS OF
EVERYONE ARE BEING MET HERE AND
WE'RE NOT GIVING IT THAT EFFORT
AND THAT THAT'S- REALLY
DISAPPOINTING. FOR ALL UP I
APOLOGIZE FOR BELIEVING THE
POINT BUT I GUESS I HAVE TO ASK
WHY IS THERE A DISTINCTION BE
MADE BETWEEN H. TWO A.
INDIVIDUALS AND KNOWLEDGE TO
INDIVIDUALS. WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE. THE H. TWO A.
PROGRAM IS A FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM OF FEDERALLY FEDERAL
PROGRAM NOT STATE PROGRAM.
RIGHT BUT WHY WHY ARE YOU
SAYING THAT THEY'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE AND EVERYONE ELSE IS.
THEIR BACKGROUND THERE IS M.
AND MY MISSING SOMETHING WHERE
IT'S JUST BECAUSE IT'S A
FEDERAL PROGRAM. THEY'RE JUST
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE AND THAT'S
THE REASON WHY OR I MEAN IT HAS
TO BE SOME OTHER. DEVICE I
THINK I CAN ASK A CLARIFYING
QUESTION JUST TO FINANCE. DO.
OKAY LET ME JUST. SO DO DO H.
TWO A. EMPLOYERS HAVE TO.
PROVIDE HOUSING AS A CONDITION
OF THE VISA. YES SIR SO
THEREFORE BECAUSE THEY ARE ABLE
TO BRING IN THIS LABOR FROM A
FOREIGN COUNTRY PART OF THE
AGREEMENT IS THEY CAN. BRING IN
FOREIGN LABOR BUT THEY HAVE TO
PROVIDE. THE EMPLOYEES HOUSING
IS THAT CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT AND SO IS IT FAIR TO
SAY THAT THE STATE DOESN'T FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE ANY OBLIGATION
TO SUBSIDIZE THAT HOUSING. IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE SINCE I WAS UP
THE POLICY. I'M SORRY MR TANG
AT MEMBER TEAM I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU I. MOST
OF. I THINK THAT IS RELATIVELY
HELPFUL I JUST AND I GUESS
THAT'S SOME TURN UNDERSTAND THE-
WITH THE RATIONALE BEHIND THE
POLICY DECISIONS ESPECIALLY AS
IT'S SO LATE IN THE IN THE
PROCESS AND THIS IS BEING
THRUST UPON US IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND.
THE BACKGROUND OF WHY THESE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING BECAUSE
YOU'RE FORCING US TO DECIDE IN.
LESS THAN FORTY FORTY EIGHT
HOURS. THE DEPRECIABLE MY
COLLEAGUES FEEDBACK I WOULD
SAY. THAT AGAIN US DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE REITERATED- THIS WAS
CLEAN UP THAT HOME WAS PROMISED
WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS IS
BILL THE SIGNED- I KNOW THAT
THERE WAS A TRAILER BILL THAT
WAS RELEASED EARLY IN THE YEAR
US DEPARTMENT FINANCE STATED- I
THINK THAT THE- LATENESS OF
THIS WAS BECAUSE- IT TOOK UNTIL
NOW TO REACH AN AGREEMENT. AND
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
RATIONALE AND ANYBODY CAN
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG. IS
THAT AGAIN- THE EMPLOYERS GOT A
BENEFIT BECAUSE THEY GET TO USE
A VISA PROGRAM TO BRING IN
LABOR. PART OF THAT. THEY HAVE
TO PROVIDE HOUSING. THAT'S THAT
IS THE AGREEMENT TO BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THE VISA PROGRAM.
THEREFORE THE STATE AT THIS
POINT DOESN'T FEEL ANY
OBLIGATION TO. SUBSIDIZE THAT
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL OR PROGRAM
BECAUSE THE BENEFIT THAT THE
EMPLOYER COTTON WAS THE VISA.
SO AGAIN THAT IS MY- THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND AGAIN THIS IS
BEEN. IN DISCUSSIONS FOR- THE
BETTER PART OF THIS BUDGET YEAR
AYE I WAS MADE AWARE OF THIS
ISSUE. VERY EARLY ON IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS IS TO- THE BACK
AND FORTH NEGOTIATIONS IT IS IT
IS- I WISH THAT THE RESOLUTION
HAVE COME SOONER. BUT I KNOW
THAT IT'S NOT BECAUSE THAT
DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN GOING ON
THEY HAVE BEEN GOING ON FOR
QUITE AWHILE. I GUESS ONE OF MY
CONCERNS IS THE- THE COLOR
NINETEEN IS KIND OF WILD CARD
BECAUSE IF SOMEONE DOES
CONTRACT OVER NINETEEN.
OBVIOUSLY AND THEY'VE GOT
FAMILY BETTER MOVE AWAY. BUT
THEY AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR THE
HOUSING FOR THE HARVEST SO. TO
ME THAT THAT CONNECTS FACTOR
THAT WASN'T PLANNED SO. IT JUST
WOULD BE. I'M TRYING TO WRAP MY
OWN AROUND THE REASONING IS
DENYING THEM THAT. IF THEY ARE
IF THEY TEST POSITIVE FOR
COVERT HAVE TO QUARANTINE. THE
BIG BIG BUT AGAIN- JUST
CLARIFY. THAT THE EMPLOYEE
ANGER AND FINANCE PLEASE
CLARIFY THIS. THE EMPLOYEE. CAN
ACCESS THAT. PROGRAM IT'S JUST
THE EMPLOYER CANNOT SO THE FOR
MORE WATER CAN. IS THAT CORRECT.
THE EMPLOYEE OF THE FARMWORKERS
AND CROWDED HOUSING THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS THE
PROGRAM WE'RE JUST NOT
SUBSIDIZING THE FARMER WHO GOT
THE BENEFIT OF THE VISA PROGRAM.
SO LET'S NOT WHICH LET'S JUST
CLARIFY WHAT THE ISSUE IS. SO
THE FARM WORKER WHO IS IN
CROWDED HOUSING AS MY
COLLEAGUES KNOW BROS OF LOCALLY
PUT HAS THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
THE PROGRAM. LOOK AT THE
QUESTIONS. GOOD LUCK AB EIGHT
TWENTY. EIGHT POINT. SANTA
BARBARA CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THANK MANY
HEARD THAT EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL- ON TUESDAY SINCE THAT
TIME TO SET SOME AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN ADDED TO THE BILL
FIRST A COUPLE OF PROVISIONS
HAVE BEEN ADDED CLARIFYING THAT
YOU SEE CAN CONTRACT OUT FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND REQUIRE WORK
THESE PROVISIONS AFFIRM THE
AUTHORITY THAT YOU SEE HAS
UNDER EXISTING LAW SECOND THE
SECOND SIDE OF PROVISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDED. I RELATE TO
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE KIDS
SAVINGS ACCOUNT PROGRAMS THE
PROVISIONS CONFORM TO SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN UNDER THE
PROVISIONS- PARENTS AT THE TIME
OF THEIR CHILD'S BIRTH WOULD BE
ASKED FOR THEIR CELL NUMBERS AS
WELL AS THEIR EMAIL ADDRESSES
IF THEY WANTED TO VOLUNTARILY
PROVIDE THEM THIS FATHER SON
PASSED MY BOARD WOULD BE ABLE
TO USE THAT INFORMATION ONLY
FOR PURPOSES. OF OPENING KIDS
ACCOUNTS. A QUICK SO OF THE NEW
PURPOSE BEFORE YOU. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. CHRIS
FERGUSON WITH FINANCE NOTHING
TO ADD ON THIS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. THE
TROUBLE WITH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- SO EXPRESSED SOME
SERIOUS RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
PROVISIONS. RESTRICTING THE
UC'S ABILITY TO CONTRACT WHEN
WE HEARD THIS BILL LAST WEEK
AND I'M VERY HAPPY THAT THOSE
PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN ALTERED
I'M STRUGGLING HOWEVER A LITTLE
BIT TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT
THE UC IS NOT PERMITTED TO
CONTRACT OUT FOR NOW SO COULD
SOMEONE. EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- WHAT CHANGES EXACTLY THE
BILL THE TRAILER BILL MADE. SO
JENNIFER PATALA FROM THE LAND
ANALYST OFFICE I'M TO CLARIFY
THOSE PROVISIONS YOU TALKED
ABOUT ON TUESDAY ARE STILL IN
THE BILL SO THE BILL WOULD
STILL PROHIBIT YOU SEE FROM
CONTRACTING OUT FOR SERVICE
RELATED WORK ON ITS STATE
FUNDED ACADEMIC BUILDINGS.
CLEANING GROUNDS CREW OF FOOD
DINING YOU SEE UNDER EXISTING
LAW IS PROHIBITED FROM DOING
THAT ANYWAYS BUT IT'S A LIMITED
TERM RESTRICTION THAT EXTENDS
THROUGH JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THE BILL YOU HEARD
ON TUESDAY WHICH IS THE SAME
VERSION THAT STILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY REMOVES THAT SUNSET DATE
SUCH THAT YOU SEE WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM CONTRACTING OUT
FOR THOSE SERVICES
INDEFINITELY. SO I THINK THOSE
CONCERNS YOU MENTIONED JUST TO
CLARIFY THERE STILL EMBEDDED IN
THE BILL BEFORE YOU. RIGHT SO
YOU KNOW I SEE THAT THAT THE
BILL. STILL PROHIBITS
CONTRACTING OUT FOR CLEANING
MAINTENANCE GROUNDS KEEPING
FOOD SERVICE RATHER WORK.
TRADITIONALLY PERFORMED BY
EMPLOYEES BUT THEN THERE ARE
EXCEPTIONS FOR. WORK DESIGNED
TO PRESERVE PROTECT OR KEEP ANY
PUBLICLY OWNED FACILITY IN A
SAFE AND USABLE CONDITION SO.
THAT TO ME THAT'S JUST OPENING
UP THE DOOR FOR LITIGATION
BECAUSE- OR ARE WE ARE WE NOT
THE FOR LACK OF SPECIFICITY
HERE ARE WE OPENING- UP-
SCRUTINY ON EXACTLY WHAT IS
REQUIRED TO KEEP A BUILDING IN
SAFE CONDITION YOU KNOW AS
GROUNDS KEEPING PART OF THAT.
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT IS YOU
COULD ARGUE THAT IT'S NOT- YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT- WHAT DO THINK
ABOUT THAT. UNFORTUNATELY THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A BETTER QUESTION
MAYBE FOR LEGISLATIVE
COUNCILLOR FOR LAWYERS I'M
THERE IS PROVISION AND- I THINK
IT'S THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT I'M
SORRY THE LABOR CODE TODAY.
THAT DOES ALLOW YOU SEE TO GO
OUT FOR A VERY SIMILAR THINGS
AND THE THINGS BEFORE YOU
CONSTRUCTION. RENOVATION OF
REPAIR WORK ON THIS LANGUAGE
BEFORE YOU MY READ OF IT IS IT
IS SLIGHTLY MORE SPECIFIC WHEN
IT COMES TO THE OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS LIKE PAINT DEAN AND
GLAZING. EXISTING LAW IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE GENERAL SO THE
CURRENT CONCERNS YOU RAISE THAT
MAYBE THERE IS BECOMING A
BLURRED LINE. BETWEEN THIS MORE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ON PAINTING
AND GLAZING I'M EXCITED ABOUT.
I MIGHT BE AN ISSUE BUT- I
WOULD BE GOING A LITTLE BIT
BEYOND- IT'S MORE OF A LEGAL
QUESTION AS TO WHAT GROUPS
WOULD BE CONCERNED THAT WHAT
YOUR LIABILITY MIGHT BE. THANK
YOU. WELL THE ONLY REASON I
BRING IT UP IS I'M A BIG
BELIEVER IN BEING AS SPECIFIC
AS WE CAN WHEN WE PUT LANGUAGE
LIKE THIS IN THE BILLS BECAUSE
I WOULD. PREFER THAT WE HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. HERE WE'RE
CRAFTING THELEGISLATION AND
NOT OPEN IT UP. TO LAWYERS
ARGUING ABOUT WHAT WE MENTIONED
WHAT WE DID NOT MEAN. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SB FIFTY TWO TO THE
WORKER PROTECTION TRAILER BILL.
HELLO. EARNING AGAIN CAROLINE
CHIU FROM LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SB EIGHT TWENTY TWO AS A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS RELATED TO
JOB PROTECTED LEAVE AND PAID
SICK LEAVE I'LL HIGHLIGHT THREE
OF THEM FOR YOU TODAY FIRST R.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO STOP A
MEDIATION PILOT PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING THE MEDIATION WOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO SMALL EMPLOYERS
THOSE EMPLOYERS WITH FIFTEEN
FIVE TO NINETEEN EMPLOYEES
PRIOR TO HAVE AN EMPLOYEE
FILING A LAWSUIT THAT ALLEGES
THE BUSINESS DID NOT FOLLOW THE
STATE'S JOB PROTECTED LEAVE LOS.
IF MEDIATION FAILS LAWSUITS
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO PROCEED AS
USUAL. THE MEDIATION PROGRAM
WOULD ONLY GO INTO AFFECTED THE
STATE AN AXE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE TO REQUIRE SMALL
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE. THE SECOND
PROVISION THAT I'LL HIGHLIGHT
ARE CREATES A SUPPLEMENTAL TWO
WEEK PAID SICK LEAVE PROGRAM
FOR FOOD INDUSTRY EMPLOYEES
AFFECTED BY KOBE NINETEEN.
THIRD SECTOR EMPLOYEES WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE IF THEIR ORDER TO
QUARANTINE OR SELF ISOLATE OR
CANNOT WORK BECAUSE OF. CLOSED
DUE TO COVE IN TRANSMISSION.
THIS PROVISION LARGELY CODIFIES
THE GOVERNOR'S ODD APRIL
SIXTEENTH EXECUTIVE ORDER. THE
LAST CRUISE AND THEN I'LL
HIGHLIGHT I'VE- THE IS- ONE
THAT CREATES A SUPPLEMENTAL TWO
WEEK PAID SICK LEAVE PROGRAM
FOR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL EMERGENCY
PAID SICK LEAVE ENOUGH-
FAMILIES FIRST. CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF ACT. SPECIFICALLY THE
STATE SUPPLEMENTAL TO REPEAT
SICKLY PROGRAM WOULD COVER
HEALTHCARE WORKERS EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL. AND EMPLOYEES. AND
EMPLOYEES OF BUSINESSES WITH
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES NATIONWIDE. WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. MISTER WITHOUT. MARK
COMMENT THAN A QUESTION THIS IS
ONE OF THE BILLS THAT I AM VERY
DISAPPOINTED WAS RAISED SO LATE
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
HAVE BEEN DEBATING CORONA VIRUS
RELATED RELIEF LEGISLATION FOR
THE LAST THREE MONTHS IN THIS
BODY TO ME IT IS COMPLETELY
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT THIS
LANGUAGE SHOULD BE INTRODUCED
INTO A BILL ON FRIDAY THE DAY
OF THE WEEKEND BEFORE THE
MONDAY OF THE LAST DAY OF
SESSION. BOB THE SECOND BALL I
DON'T SEE HOW THIS IS POSSIBLY
A BUDGET BILL I MEAN WE'VE
WE'VE GOT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR APPROPRIATION IN HERE
OTHER THAN THAT THE MEAT OF THE
BILL IS A VERY SUBSTANTIVE
POLICY ISSUE THAT I THINK IS
MORE TO PROPERLY DEBATED POLICY
COMMITTEE BUT I MEAN LASTLY LET
ME JUST POINT OUT THAT THE
EIGHTY COMMON ARGUMENT THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING HERE WE TALK
ABOUT PUTTING MORE RESTRICTIONS
ON THE STATE'S EMPLOYERS WITH
RESPECT TO CORONAVIRUS IS THIS
MISCONCEPTION THAT. IF WE FORCE
EMPLOYERS TO PAY MORE THEN
THAT'S JUST MEANS THAT THEY'LL
MAKE A LITTLE LESS PROFIT THIS
YEAR I MEAN LONG TERM IT'S A
ZERO SUM GAME SOMEBODY HAS TO
PAY THE PRICE FOR THAT OUR
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING THEY CAN'T
CONTINUE TO STAY IN BUSINESS IF
LONG TERM THEY DON'T MAKE MORE
THAN THEY SPEND SO THE LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCE OF EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO HERE IS TO RESIST
WHEN WE PUT A NEW RESTRICTION
ON- HAVING TO PAY BENEFITS FROM
AN EMPLOYER IN AN ATTEMPT TO
TRY AND MITIGATE THIS
CORONAVIRUS SITUATION IS LONG
TERM OR FORCING THOSE COMPANIES
TO RAISE PRICES IN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS REGRESSIVE AND HURTS
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE WERE
TRYING TO HELP. SO A I PROBABLY
STARTED UP IT BUT DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THIS BILL
IN FRONT OF US TODAY. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER. FURTHER THOUGHTS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS THE ONLY
COMMENT I DO THINK R. I.
STRAHAN'S A FAIR POINT I THINK-
WE DID DO A GOOD JOB THIS YEAR
OF TRYING TO LIMIT AS MANY OF
THE LAST MINUTE- PROPOSALS AS
WELL AS WE KNOW- YOU KNOW HUMAN
NATURE IS WHEN YOU HAVE A
DEADLINE PEOPLE- START TO. TAKE
IT MORE SERIOUSLY AND THERE'S
ALWAYS ISSUES THAT END UP BEING
RESOLVED AT THE LAST MINUTE-
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE KNOW
HAS BEEN IN A VERY IMPORTANT
AS WE SEEN MANY ESSENTIAL
WORKERS I GET SICK. AND
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE MANY
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE HOURLY
AND WHEN THEY GET SICK THEY
DON'T GET PAID- THERE DID NOT
GETTING SICK LEAVE- THE ARE
REALLY HAVING TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
GOING TO WORK AND GETTING PAID
TO PAY THEIR BILLS OR- STAYING
HOME AND NOT GETTING PAID OR IF
THEY GO TO WORK THEY GET SICK
THERE ON A THREAT TO GET
CORONAVIRUS AND WE ARE. WE ARE
VERY LUCKY ONE WHICH YOU ARE WE
ARE HERE AT WORK- AND- DOING
OUR JOB WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
PRECAUTIONS TO LIMIT OUR
EXPOSURE AT THE SAME TIME WE
HAVE BEEN COLLECTING OUR
SELLERS SO AGAIN- I APPRECIATE
THE BUSTERS COME INTO THINK
THERE THROUGH THE WALL WELL
SAID- BUT I THINK WE DO ARE WE
ARE TRYING TO FIND A BALANCE
BETWEEN TRYING TO. ENSURE THAT
THE A SOCIAL WORKERS WHO WE ARE
SENDING INTO THE GROCERY STORES
AND TO THE FACTORIES INTO THE
PROCESSING PLANTS- YOU KNOW
RISKING EXPOSURE MANY OF WHOM
HAVE GOTTEN EXPOSED THAT THEY
ALSO HAVE ON SOME OF THE VERY
BENEFITS THAT WE HAVE AS WELL
IN TERMS OF. SUPPORT SO WITHOUT
A SINGLE OTHER COMMENTS WE WERE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO S. B. EIGHT
TWO THREE. WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I WILL BE
PRESENTING SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE WHICH WOULD REMIND THE
STATE'S DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE DJJ TO THE COUNTIES. IT
WAS FIRST ISCUSSED IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON TUESDAY AUGUST
TWENTY FIFTH AND WAS IN
RESPONSE TO- ADMINISTRATION MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL ALSO WOULD
REALIGN THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND COUNTIES.
I'LL BE FOCUS M COMMENTS DOWN
THE SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE SENSE AND
INTERIM SINCE TUESDAY. WILD
INTENT REMAINS A CLOSE DJ JAY A
SPECIFIC CLOSURE DATE IS NOT
SPECIFIED IN THE CURRENT
VERSION OF S. B. TWENTY THREE.
AND NTAKE WOULD CLOSE ON JULY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE- WITH
CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS. FOR THE
YOUTH YOU ARE ADMITTED TO DJ
AFTER JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THEY COUNTY AND PEOPLE ARE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY THREE
THE COUNTIES AND PAY A FEE OF
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR-
CURRENTLY COUNTY TO PAY A FEE
OF TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. FOUR YEARS FOR WHO ARE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY THIRTY
IN OUR HOUSE AND DJ. THE
REALIGNMENT WOULD BE FUNDED
THROUGH TO GRANT PROGRAM. THE
FIRST WOULD BE A ONE TIME.
GRANT OF NINE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TO PROVIDE COUNTIES
THE RESOURCES FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. AT REALLY NEEDS
IMPROVEMENTS TO ASSIST IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL CONTINUUM
OF CARE. AND THE SECOND WOULD
BE AN ONGOING BLOCK GRANT. TO
SUPPORT COUNTY BASED CUSTODY
CARE AND SUPERVISION OF
REALIGNED YOU. THAT GRANT WOULD
START AT THIRTY NINE POINT NINE
MILLION AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AN INCREASE TO TWO
HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND
ONGOING WITH ADJUSTMENTS FOR
GROWTH AND- JUVENILE JUSTICE
GROWTH SPECIAL ACCOUNT. THAT
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. WOULD BE BASED ON
A FORMULA THAT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT EACH COUNTY CHAIRED THE
STATE'S YOUTH POPULATION. PRIOR
USE OF DJJ IN RECENT YEARS AND
THE NUMBER OF YOU THAT YOU TO
CARE FOR SERIOUS OR VIOLENT
OFFENSES. BEFORE. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE THE
METHODOLOGY FOR DISTRIBUTING
THE FUNDING WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
REVISION. TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING IS DISTRIBUTED ON NOW
THE BEST IMPROVES OUTCOMES FOR
THE REAL LINE POPULATIO. LIKE
PRIOR VERSIONS COUNTIES WOULD
BE GUARANTEED A MINIMUM FUNDING
AMOUNT OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND WOULD HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO CONTACT
OTHER COUNTIES TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. COUNTIES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT PLANS FOR
STATE APPROVAL BEFORE RECEIVING
FUNDING. BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE THE
PASSWORD BEING VIEWED BY THE%
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION WHICH WOULD BE A
NEW STATE ENTITY ESTABLISHED
UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. ON JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE OFFICE
MISSION WOULD BE TO PROMOTE
TRAUMA RESPONSIVE. JOHN
CULTURALLY INFORMED SERVICES
FOR YOUTH NVOLVED IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
SUPPORT THE YOUTH SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD AND
HELP THEM BECOME RESPONSIBLE
THRIVING AND ENGAGE MEMBERS OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES. THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE. HI
COUNTERPART IN A FINANCE- HAPPY
TO BE HERE TODAY TO BE IN
AGREEMENT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON THIS IMPORTANT REFORM I'M NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THAT AND
THEN IT ACT ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. MISTER
COOPER THANK YOU MISTER TANK.
THERE'S NO REASON THIS HAS TO
HAPPEN NOW. THE STATE WANTS TO
SHIFT THIS PROBLEMS TO THE
COUNTIES. WHEN THE MIST OF A
WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC CAN IS LOST
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BECAUSE THE
SHUT DOWN THE STATE IS RELEASED
THOUSANDS OF OFFENDERS. THE
MINISTRATION INSIST ON DOING
THIS FORCED REALIGNMENT THEY'RE
SITTING COUNTIES UP TO FAIL.
THE MINISTER NOTHING TO ADDRESS
THE REAL ISSUES TRAPPING
COUNTIES WITH MAJOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROJECT THAT BELONGS TO
THE STATE. THE STORE ABOUT A
YEAR AGO THIS PROGRAM IS GOING
TO BE SHIFTED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS TO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. AND
NOTHING LATE IN THE LAP OF THE
COUNTIES. TO A POINT WHERE THE
PROBATION CHIEFS ARE OPPOSED.
ONE MAJOR ISSUE HERE IS THAT A
BIRD IS BEING GIVEN TO THEM IN
ADDITION TO THE STATE
OVERSIGHT. AN EXTREME. LEVEL
REMAINS. THAT CAN CAUSE FOR
FINANCE CAN YOU TELL ME HOW
SECTION THIRTY ONE. NINE TWELVE
HOUR PAGE THIRTY EIGHT OF THIS
PROPOSAL WILL AFFECT THE
COUNTY'S. ARE THEY GETTING
PENALIZED FOR NOT MEETING ALL
THE REQUIREMENTS IN A TIMELY
MANNER THIS BILL. SORRY I'M
TRYING. AND FOR SECTION THIRTY
ONE HERE SO I CAN MAKE SURE I
HAVE THE YES THAT'S THE ONE-
NINE TWELVE OR PAGE THIRTY
EIGHT. OF THE PROPOSAL. SO THE
INTENT HERE IS THAT- OUR
PROPOSAL STARTS FUNDING COUNTY
IS AT TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PER ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS AND PROVIDING
MONEY. IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO HOWEVER GIVEN
THE REALIZATION THAT THIS WILL
BE YOU KNOW IT'LL TAKE LONGER
FOR COUNTIES TO HAVE PROGRAMS
IN PLACE WHERE ALLOWING CERTAIN
USED TO STILL COUNTY DJJ. SO
BASIC THIS PROVISION IS
STRUCTURED SO THAT IF A YOUTH
DOES COME TO THE STATE- WELL
THE STATE'S ACTUALLY PROVIDING
FUNDING TO THEMFOR THAT USE
THEY WERE PROVIDED THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE TO PASS A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
IT'S KIND OF. THE STATE
RECRUITING COSTS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BLOCK BLOCK
GRANT FORMULA BUT AS A WAY OF
ALLOWING CERTAIN USED TO STILL
COME TO THE STATE IF I COUNTY
DOESN'T HAVE THEIR PROGRAMS UP.
AND TO AVOID THEM GOING TO THE
ADULT COURT SYSTEM AS AN
ALTERNATIVE SO RIGHT NOW THE
STATE'S PAY. TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER OFFENDER
CORRECT. TWENTY FOURTH NINE
FOUR THOUSAND IS GONNA GO TO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SO
WITH. A FIVE FOLD INCREASE.
WELL THAT'S OVER THE TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND IS BEEN A LONG
STANDING- THE AMOUNT THAT WAS
KIND OF USED AS A DETERRENT.
THE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AS I LAID OUT IS AT
THIS POINT THE STATE WILL BE
PAYING COUNTIES TO. FOR THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF MAINTAINING
THOSE YEARS. THAT IF THEY SEND
A YOUTH TO DJJ AT THAT POINT
NOW WEARING CURRENT NOT COST
FOR SOMEONE THAT WE ASK THAT
ARE THAT WE ARE PAYING THEM TO
COVER. A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IS HELPING THE
STATE RECOUP A PORTION OF THAT
COST THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
PACKED PAPER THAT WE'VE BEEN ON
THAT WERE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
COUNTY. SO IT'S DIFFERENT IT'S
A DIFFERENT FISCAL STRUCTURE
BECAUSETHE TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND RELATED TO YOU'VE JUST
COMING TO THE STATE AND WAS A
SEPARATE. AT YOU KNOW
DISINCENTIVE PROGRAM A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND JUST AS A
WAY OF SAYING. YES WE WANT TO
STILL MAKE SURE THAT YOU DON'T
GO TO THE ADULT SYSTEM SO FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME WE WANT THEM TO
COME TO DJJ AT THEY DON'T HAVE
PROGRAMS READY LOCALLY. BUT
SINCE WE'RE ALREADY PAYING YOU
FOR THAT USE- WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO RECOUP SOME PORTION OF
THAT COST GIVEN THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE THE ONE WHO'S
HOUSING AND CARING FOR THEM.
CHAPTER FOUR TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
TURN THE AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
THIS PROGRAM. IN THE OFFICE OF
YOU THINK COMMITTEE REAP
RESTORATION TO THE OMBUDSMAN.
WHO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
INVESTIGATE AND DETERMINE
OUTCOMES THESE COMPLAINTS. HOW
DOES THIS CONFLICT WITH OUR
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS POLICY
AND PROCEDURES IN PLACE AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY LABOR.
CONTRACTS WHICH ARE LEGALLY
BINDING. SO THE YOUNG BATSMAN
IS. HERE IS BEING ESTABLISHED
LIKE MANY OTHER ON THAT DEMAND
AND I'M TO BE AN ADVISER IN AN
ADVOCACY ROLE IT DOES NOT HAVE
ENFORCEABLE INVESTIGATIVE
AUTHORITY AND CANNOT SUBPOENA
SO WE DON'T REALLY WE DON'T SEE
THIS AS LIKE A- A SEPARATE-
INSPECTOR GENERAL OR SOMETHING
WITH. A LOT MORE OF THE- WE SEE
THIS AS A ROLE I CAN HELP.
TAKEN COMPLAINTS RESOLVED
COMPLAINTS- REFER COMPLAINTS.
AND TRY TO REMEDY THOSE THE
BEST THE- WAY POSSIBLE IN A
MORE STRUCTURED CLEAR REPORTING
SYSTEM. MOVING FORWARD SO THAT
FOLKS- ARE ABLE TO SEE THEIR
ISSUES- SALT. SODIUM BUSSMANN
DOESN'T INVEST. INVESTIGATES
COMPLAINTS OKAY AND JUST ONE
MORE THING I TALKED ABOUT LAST
WEEK I'M NOT IN LABOR THE POINT
BUT- YOU STILL HAVEN'T
RECONCILED. DJS PROGRAM FOR SEX
OFFENDERS. THAT WE KNOW IS TOP
NOTCH. AND THE REASON I GOT TOP
NOTCH IS BECAUSE OF THIS I MEAN
DIDN'T SUIT IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OVER THE
YEARS. SO YOU WERE TOP NOTCH
PROGRAM HERE YOU'RE GOING TO
COUNTIES. SO THE COUNTIES
GETTING SOME MONEY. BUT BUT
THERE'S DJJ OR CORRECTIONS
THEY'VE BEEN SUED TO HELL AND
BACK. AB ONE H NINE. IF YOU
LOOK AT IT. IS RESULT IN THE
SAME THING FOR THE COUNTY THE
COUNTY BEING SUED BY THE PRISON
LAW OFFICE FOR. MEDICAL OR
HEALTH CARE IN OTHER ISSUES-
SITE CARE THINGS LIKE THAT THAT.
EXPOSE THE STATE TO ANOTHER
BEING EXPOSED SO MY QUESTION IS.
WHAT IS A RUSSIAN NUMBER TWO.
AND WE BETTER OFF SERVING THESE
KIDS LETTING STAY WHERE THEY
ARE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHAT BILL WORKS ITS EFFECTIVE
AS TRIED AND PROVEN. OR SITTING
IN THE COUNTIES WHERE I SAID IF
YOU WILL NOT IS NOT BEEN A
SUCCESS WITH THE COULD THE
RECIDIVISM RATE AS HIGH AS
HELL- THE GOVERNOR OR HIS STAFF
CAN EVEN TELLS WE SAID AS A
RAISE FOR THE COUNTIES SO. WILL
HAPPEN THESE KIDS GOING TO
COUNTIES- OR THEIR LIVES WILL
BE BETTER. I YES DEFINITELY I
THINK THAT'S THE INTENT OF THE
PROPOSAL HERE IS THAT- THE
COUNTIES HAVE MADE A LOT OF
IMPROVEMENTS- UNDER THAT TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN REALIGNMENT-
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT SAYS
THAT- YOU'D DO BETTER WHEN
THEY'RE CLOSE TO THEIR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES. SO THAT WAS
SORT OF THE INTENT OR PURPOSE
BEHIND THIS PROPOSAL. AS FAR
AS- THE SEX OFFENDER TREATMENT
PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN IN
DISCUSSION WITH COUNTIES FOR
MONTHS AOUT. WHETHER THEY
THINK THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY OR
ABILITY TO ROUGHLY. SOMETHING
AND TAKE ON THESE CHALLENGES
WITH AND GIVEN THAT TRACK
RECORD THEY DO FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT THEY CAN DO THAT.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'VE INCREASED
OUR AMOUNT PER YOU FROM
1-002-500-0200 TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. WE HAVE A START UP
GRANT OF NINE POINT SIX MILLION
THAT'S RELATED TO PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT. AS IT RELATES
SPECIFICALLY TO SEX OFFENDER
TREATMENT. THAT THEIR- THERE'S
A SMALL NUMBER OF YOUTH THAT.
ARE AT DJJ FOR THOSE TIMES.
MAINTENANCE AND IT'S NOT REALLY
EXPECTATIONS AND OUR
CONVERSATIONS THAT EACH COUNTY
WOULD HAVE SOME KIND OF A
SPECIALIZED PROGRAM LIKE THAT.
THE START UP GRANTS WOULD
PROBABLY BE TARGETED AT A
COUPLE COUNTIES I FEEL LIKE TO
HAVE THE CAPACITY. TO ACTUALLY
DO THAT PROGRAM WELL. AND AN
ESTABLISHED SYSTEM STRUCTURES
AROUND THAT AND THEN WORK WITH
THEIR NEIGHBORING COUNTIES.
THROUGH THEIR STUFF.
RELATIONSHIPS TO PROVIDE THAT
TYPE OF CARE. SO THAT'S WHY WE
WORK HOW WE THINK THIS WILL
WORK LONG TERM- AS FAR AS WHY
NOW- THAT BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL SYSTEM NEED CERTAINTY ON
THIS ISSUE. AND THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT REFORM. IT IS A SAD
THIS BUDGET. IS A LONG TERM
IMPLEMENTATION. JULY ONE WE ARE
NOT SHIFTING ALL EIGHT YOU THE
DJ. CAL IS IT'LL BE A SLOW
EMPLOYMENT. HAS CASES ARE
ADJUDICATED OVERTIME AND SO
WE'RE WE'RE THINKING IT'LL BE
AT LEAST OVER FOUR YEARS FOR
FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM. AND WE EXPECT TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS. AND
MODIFY PROPOSED ARE PROPOSED AS
WE LEARN NEW THINGS AND NEED TO
PAY FOR IT. SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT START NOW GIVEN THAT
UNCERTAINTY ON BOTH ENDS AND-
IT DEFINITELY THERE'S TIME TO.
ADDRESS ISSUES AS THEY ARISE
OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS MY
LAST QUESTION IS A BIG COUNTIES
MAY BE ABLE TO HANDLE THIS AND
DEAL WITH IT. BUT A LOT OF
SMALL COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES THE MONEY TO DEAL
WITH THIS. SO THE ELOISE.
ALAMEDA'S THE CENSUS OF THE BIG
COUNTIES CAN DO THAT. BUT FOR
THOSE KIDS THAT GO TO A SMALL
COUNTIES THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES. OR THE CAPACITY. TO
IMPROVE THESE KIDS LIVES. TO ME
THE MONEY'S NOT GOING TO BE
THERE HASN'T BEEN THERE THEY
DON'T HAVE AFFECTED PROGRAMS.
AND YEAH YOU WANT TO SIT ON
HOLD BECAUSE THE FAMILIES. BUT
I CAN'T GET THE PROPER
TREATMENT. WE'RE SAYING THIS
THIS ENTIRE PROGRAM IS SET UP
FOR FAILURE FOR MOST THE COUNTY
WAS NOT LARGE. COUNTIES AND
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY. SO IT
DOES THE RULE COUNTIES BEEN A
CONCERN OR REPORT OF A POINTOF. TIME OUR CONVERSATIONS AND
I THINK. THEY DO HAVE
ESTABLISHED RELATIONSHIPS
AMONGST EACH OTHER AND AS I
DESCRIBE I THINK IT'S WORKING
THOSE THINGS THOSE THINGS OUT
ABOUT. IF THEY HAVE A YOUTH
THAT COMMITS A SERIOUS SEX
OFFENCE THE NEEDS. AND ALL OF A
SPECIALIZED TREATMENT WHERE
WOULD THEY GO ABOUT DOING THAT
IN SOME KIND OF REGIONAL
FORMAT. AND SO- YOU KNOW WITH
TIME I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
WORK THAT OUT AND IT'S NOT THE
EXPECTATION. OF THE STATE I
THINK OR EVEN LOCALLY THAT THEY
WOULD THEY WOULD BUILD THEIR
PROGRAMS IN SUCH A WAY. THAT
THAT'S REALLY A WISHFUL
RESPONSE. BECAUSE ALTHOUGH
SMALL COUNTIES WE GATHER SO IT
CAN POOL RESOURCES BUT STILL
GOING TODAY. IT'S STILL A VERY.
LIMITED AMOUNT OF RESOURCES A
SMALL COUNTIES HAVE SO. THEY
CAN PUT TOGETHER MAKE IT
EFFECTIVE. AND I WERE I REFER
COUNTY FOR THIRTY YEARS SO.
IT'S TOUGH FOR THE SMALL
COUNTIES OUT THERE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS START WORK. YES I
WANT TO- BASICALLY THANK THOSE
WHO BEEN WORKING TO TRY O COME
TO SOME CONCLUSION AND RESOLVE
THE ISSUE- WITH REGARDS TO THE
RELATIONSHIP. USE ME WITH THE
COUNTIES IN THE AND THE KIND OF
OVERSIGHT THAT'LL BE CENTRAL-
TO MAKE THIS EFFECTIVE PROGRAM
SO I'M WAS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
NEW LANGUAGE THAT'S COME OUT.
WITH REGARDS TO THAT- WE HAVE
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT PROBABLY
IF WE HAD A VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM OF FOR DJJ
WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE
TOUCHING IT AT THIS POINT- BUT
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF RECIDIVISM
MEDIC EXISTEN DJJ. AND SO THE
HIGH LEVEL OF STUDENTS
RETURNING- AND BASICALLY ALMOST
BUILDING A PIPELINE TO PRISON
IS UNACCEPTABLE OF THE
ADVOCATES WHO WORK DIRECTLY
WITH THESE KIDS WHO ARE A PART
OF A HOST OF COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS- SOME OF THOSE WHO
ARE ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAMS
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF US. BASICALLY
MAKING THE- THE MOVEMENT AWAY
FROM WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
BIT OF PUTTING IT BACK TO THE
COUNTIES AND IN A MUCH EASIER
WAY FOR KIDS TO HAVE ACCESS.
ONLY AND FOR THE FAMILIES ALSO
HAVE SIMILAR ACCESS TO PROGRAMS
THAT RELATE TO THE KIDS- WE
KNOW THERE ARE SMALL COUNTIES
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE SAID ALSO THAT. YOU KNOW
THAT ARE OF A PERSON'S ZIP CODE
SHOULD NOT DETERMINE THE
SERVICES THAT THEY RECEIVE THAT
THEY RECEIVE FROM AND FROM
THERE- FROM THE COUNTIES AND SO
THE WORK WILL BE UPON THE
COUNTIES AS WELL AS THE
ADVOCATES TO BASICALLY MAKE
SURE. THAT EVERY CHILD HAS THE
RIGHT PLACEMENT WITH REGARDS TO
WHAT SERVICES THEY MAY NEED BUT
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
WE DO NOT HAVE QUOTE UNQUOTE A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM AS SUCH IT
MAY BE SUCCESSFUL TO SOME. BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OF
RECIDIVISM IN YOUNG PEOPLE'S
PROGRAMS WE CAN'T TOLERATE THAT
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE POINT
WHERE IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE AND
THAT- WE ARE NOT JUST SIMPLY
FEEDING THE NEXT LEVEL OF
INCARCERATION- THAT WE
SOMETIMES SEE SO- I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A JOURNEY FOR EVERYBODY
WHO'S BEEN WORKING ON A VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF ALL THE EFFORTS
THAT HAVE GONE INTO THIS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT BEEN AN EASY
ONE. AND WE KNOW THIS IS NOT A
QUICK FALL DISCUSSION BECAUSE
OF THE FACT IT'S TAKEN US TO A
TWO YEARS OR MORE TO GET TO
THIS POINT WHERE WE ARE WITH
REGARDS TO THE TRANSFER THAT'S
THE IT- THE WORD CAME OUT
INITIALLY AND EVERYBODY WAS.
ALL EXCITED BUT REALIZE THAT
THERE WAS A LOT OF. DETAILS I
NEED TO BE WORKED OUT AND WE
STILL. MORE TO BE WORK OUT WITH
REGARDS TO MAKING SURE. THAT
THE DECISIONS WE MAKE WITH THE
GARDEN YOUNG PEOPLE IS A GOOD
DECISION SO. YOU KNOW ALL THE
RESEARCH AND INFORMATION SHOWS
THAT THIS IS THAT THIS WE'RE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND BUT IT'S GONNA TAKE A WHILE
TO MOVE IT IT DOESN'T MOVE
EASILY AND WE KNOW TO TAKE
THREE TO FOUR YEARS BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY. SEE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK DR GRANT.
OTHER COMMENTS COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR ME OTHER FOR
FINANCE OR ALEJO- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. THAT THE
CURRENT POPULATION OF THE
JUDGES JUST A LITTLE BIT SHORT
OF EIGHT HUNDRED IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT IT THAT IS
CORRECT IN MY MIND OR STANDING
WAS THAT. THE YOUTH WHO ARE IN
THE CURRENT POPULATION AREN'T
BEING MOVED THE BILL REALLY IS
IMPACTING THE POPULATION AS
THEY COME INTO THE SYSTEM. YES
DEFINITELY DEFINITELY INITIALLY
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
LONGER TERM COMMERCE
CONVERSATION OF DJJ GETS REALLY
SMALL BUT THAT'S MANY YEARS OUT.
GOT SPENT THE DAY BASICALLY
WHAT WE'RE REALLY DISCUSSING IS
AS WE DO DJJ INTAKE OF THE-
THREE HUNDRED OR SO YOU THINK
YEAR- WHERE WHERE ARE THEY
GOING. IS THAT CORRECT. AND TO
OTHERS. THE COUNTY'S MAIN
OPPOSITION OR CONSTERNATION
HASN'T REALLY BEEN ABOUT.
WHETHER OR NOT THE PROGRAM IS
WORKING OR NOT HASN'T REALLY
BEEN ABOUT MONEY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. HI YEAH I MEAN
I THINK IT'S THEIR CONCERN TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM- OPERATE IN A
IN A WAY THAT WORKS FOR THEM
LONG TERM AS WELL. YES FINDINGS
BEEN OF THAT- AND AT LAKE AND
SORT OF LIKE HOW ON HOW WE CAN
STRAIN THEIR ABILITY TO OPERATE
THEIR PROGRAMS HAS BEEN A
CONCERN YEAH. RIGHT BUT IT BUT
AREN'T AREN'T THE REASON THEY
COUNTIES ARE SUCH FINANCIAL.
STREETS REGARDING- PUBLIC
FIFTIES BECAUSE THEY MADE VERY
POOR DECISIONS. BUILT EVEN ALL
FACILITIES THAT ARE NEARLY
EMPTY MY UNDERSTANDING IS YOU
KNOW THE AVERAGE OCCUPANCY OF
THESE JUVENILE JAILS ACROSS THE
COUNTIES LIKE ROUGHLY BY
202230% ACROSS THE STATE. YES
CURRENT FACILITIES ARE FILLED
AT A VERY LOW RATE COMPARED TO
THEIR OWN CAPACITY YES AND NO
ONE IS EXPENSIVE YOU GOT EMPTY.
GOT EMPTY JAILS LOT OF PEOPLE
GETTING. YOU KNOW PAID ON THE
PRISON GRAVY TRAIN. AND YOU
KNOW THERE'S NO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
WHAT'S VERY CONCERNING. IN
TERMS OF FEEDBACK FROM THE
COUNTIES NO NOBODY TALKED
ABOUT. THE KIDS THE EIGHT
HUNDRED KIDS I DIDN'T HEAR
ANYTHING ABOUT. WHETHER THIS
WAS GOOD FOR THE KIDS ARE BAD
FOR THE KIDS HE WAS GONNA IN
FACT HE WAS REALLY ABOUT HEY
GIVE US THE MONEY IT WILL TAKE
THE MONEY AND WE DON'T WANT ANY
OVERSIGHT. SO IT'S UNFORTUNATE
FROM THE COUNTY POINT OF VIEW.
THAT THEY WANT TO STAND BEHIND
A FAILED PROGRAM DR WEBER
TALKED ABOUT IT. THREE OUT OF
FOUR YOUTH GET RE ARRESTED. SO
THAT THE 25% SUCCESS RATE. YOU
GOT A TWENTY TO THIRTY IT'S
AUGUST TWENTY FIVE LIKE
AMERICAN NUMBER YOU GOT A 25%
SUCCESS RATE YOU GOT A 25%
ROUGHLY OCCUPANCY. AND YOU GOT
COUNTY'S BLEEDING MONEY ON
THESE EMPTY JAILS LOOKING FOR
THE STATE THE BILL ABOUT. AND I
THINK THE STATE IS TIRED OF
THIS FAILURE ON THE COUNTY'S
PART. SO WE HAVE COME UP WITH
THE SYSTEM. THAT WE THINK IS
ARE BETTER GOING TO WORK. AND
ON TOP OF IT YES- MICHAEL IF NO
GROUP IS CORRECT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE. A LITTLE BIT OVERSIGHT
AND I KNOW THEY ARE FIGHTING
THIS TOOTH AND NAIL BECAUSE
THEY ACTUALLY WANT THE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER
YOUTH THAT'S WHAT THEY WANTED
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING I'M GETTING MY
HEAD SHAKE THAT'S WHAT THE
COUNTIES UNDER SO I'M JUST
PUTTING UP WITH THE COUNTIES
WANT. THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PER USE. THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YOUTH WE
SAID NOTED THAT WE'RE GIVING
THEM TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR AND
THEY'RE SAYING IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
SO I KIND OF FEEL LIKE ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH BECAUSE IF WE CAN
GET. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT INTO SUB
TO. YOU TALK ABOUT A VERY
DIFFERENT KIND OF PROGRAM. AND
SO FOR ME. I THINK WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE CAN DO BETTER
THAN THE 25% SIX US RATE THAT
IS A COMPLETE FAILURE. WE CAN
DO BETTER THAN TO HAVE THESE
EMPTY JAILS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ACROSS THE COUNTY TO BLEED
MONEY. AND BOY IF THE COUNTIES
CAN'T FIGURE OUT. HOW TO HELP
THESE. EIGHT HUNDRED OR SO
YOUTH AT A PRICE OF TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YOU. MAYBE WE NEED SOME NEW
LEADERSHIP IN THE COUNTIES.
DOCTORS BOND LIKELY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NUMBER ONE ONE THE
REASONS THE JUVENILE HALLS ARE
EMPTY NOW AND THIS THIS IS REAL
IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN THERE TALK
TO PEOPLE. IF YOU RAPE SOMEBODY
YOU GET OUT THE SAME DAY SO YOU
COULD ASK GROUP SOMEONE YOU GO
BACK TO SCHOOL YOUR CLASS AND
SAY PERSON YOU RAPED. IF YOU
SHOOT SOMEONE YOU DON'T KEEP
YOUR BECAUSE THE JUVENILE HALL
ANYMORE IF YOU ROB SOMEBODY
WITH A GUN THEY DON'T KEEP AND
BECAUSE YOU DO A WHOLE ANYMORE
SO A LOT OF FOLKS DEPENDING ON
WHAT YOUR FLAVOR THE DAY IS IF
YOU'RE OKAY WITH A RAPIST BEING
LET OUT AND IT DOES HAPPEN MOST
KIDS. THAT'S OKAY REALIGNMENT
FOR THE COUNTY JAILS. BEEN
HORRIBLE. RECIDIVISM THE
COMMISSION SCHOOL YOU HOPE.
SCHOOL IN HIS NAME. AND A LOT
OF IT COMES BACK TO SOCIETY.
AND TO FIX A SOCIETY NOT AFFECT
HIS COMMITTEE. BUNNIES
NEIGHBORHOODS. UNDERPERFORMING
SCHOOLS NO BANKS NO
SUPERMARKETS NORTH PROGRAMS
SPORTS PROGRAMS FOR KIDS SO
THERE'S A PRISON SCHOOL
PIPELINE BUT IT INVOLVES A
WHOLE LOT MORE THAN THIS. BUT
WHAT I'M SAYING IS. AB ONE OH
NINE REALIGNMENT FAIL. THIS IS
A MINI VERSION OF THAT. AND
IT'S NOT GONNA MAKE IT BETTER
AND THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF
THE THINGS TO FIX THEIR
PRIMARILY KIDS OF COLOR. SO
UNTIL SOMEONE GOES MOST
NEIGHBORHOODS IT HAS THE GUTS
TO FIX WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT.
IT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE. BECAUSE
THE SAME THINGS BEEN GOING ON
THIRTY FORTY FIFTY YEARS AND
HAS NOT CHANGED THE DOWNTOWN
REDEVELOPMENT US WE TAKE CARE
OF BUSINESS BUT WE DO TAKE CARE
OF OUR KIDS HELLO WE HAVE A
TAKING CARE OF THEM FOR YEARS
THAT HS NOT CHANGED SO THIS IS
pJUST LIKE AB ONE OH NINE WAS
ABSOLUTELY 1% BELIEVE IN IT. I
THOUGHT I THOUGHT IMPLEMENTED.
AND ADMINISTRATION STILL CAN'T
TELL ME IN FINANCE. WHAT WAS
THAT OF THE RATE IS FOR THE
COUNTY JAILS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NO IDEA. THAT'S ATROCIOUS IT'S
ACCEPTABLE TO THE STAFF THAT'S
A SINGLE TEST. FOR I MEAN I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM. HELP GROWTH
THAT THE SYSTEM IS COMPLETELY
BROKEN. THERE'S NO QUESTION.
AND I THINK WHAT WE CAN DO IS
WE CAN ACCEPT THAT THE SYSTEM
IS BROKEN. AND JUST. KEEP GOING.
OR WE CAN TRY TO CHANGE. AND I
THINK THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO TRY
TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THE FAILURE
THAT IT THE SYSTEM IS WHICH I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE GROUP THAT
THE SYSTEM HAS FAILED. AND THIS
IS A APPROACH TO TRY TO CHANGE
THAT. AND WHAT IS THE APPROACH
WITH THE APPROACH IS TO ENSURE
THAT THE- YOU ARE. IN THERE ARE
CLOSER TO THEIR FAMILIES CLOSER
TO COUNTY'S WHICH WE'VE SEEN
OVER TIME IS- OVERALL A BETTER
SITUATION ALSO WE WANT TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT I THINK
PART OF THE REASON WE HAVE SUCH
A FAILURE NOT JUST FROM THE U.
SIDE BUT WE HAVEN'T EVEN GOT TO
THE ADULT CORRECTIONS ON IT
BECAUSE A COMPLETE. ACKO FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY COMPLETE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT THE MONEY'S BEEN
SPENT IT WAS JUST MONEY GOING
HERE MONEY GO ON THERE NO ONE
TALKING ABOUT WHERE THE MONEY
WENT HOW GOT SPENT WHAT WHAT%
WAS. HAPPENING IN FACT. THE
DOCTOR WEBER AND I WE FOUGHT
HARD. OF THE LEGISLATURE NOT
JUST US BUT YOU KNOW WE WITH
OUR LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES.
FOUGHT HARD FOR THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL THE CORRECTIONS SYSTEM.
IF IT WASN'T FOR THE- INSPECTOR
GENERAL. ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
MANY OF THE ISSUES IN THE
LARGER CORRECTION SYSTEM- WE
WOULD NOT BE SEEING MANY OF THE
IMPROVEMENTS HETHER HE WAS
AROUND COVERT- WHETHER IT WAS
AROUND SOME OF THE- PRACTICES
THAT WERE HAPPENING IN VARIOUS.
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THAT'S WHAT AND THAT'S WHAT
THE SERBS DID THIS IS ABOUT
NOT. AGAIN UNEXPECTED GENERAL
BUT AGAIN PROVIDING SOME
SUNSHINE ON A SYSTEM THAT
ABSOLUTE IS NOT WORKING WE
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THAT. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. THING AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO SB. EIGHT
TO FOUR. NEARLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SB
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WOOD AS OF
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ELIMINATE THE ASSESSMENT AND
COLLECTION OF AROUND. TWENTY
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES GENERALLY RELATED TO
ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION
PROGRAMS- ARRESTING AND BOOKING
AND INDIGENT DEFENSE. REMEMBER
TO THE SPELL FOCUSES ON THE
MONEY THAT WAS SET ASIDE FOR
ALLOCATION TO COUNTIES AND
RECOGNITION OF THE REVENUE LOSS
FROM THE ELIMINATION OF THE
FEES. THE BILL NOW SPECIFICALLY
APPROPRIATE SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR-
ALLOCATION TO THE COUNTIES AND
ALSO INCLUDES LANGUAGE- OF THE
INTENSE TO INCLUDE THE FINAL
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY AS PART
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN EDWARDS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
HAS GONE INTO NEGOTIATING THIS
OP PIECE OF LEGISLATION WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND- REACHING
AGREEMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY IN ADOPTING THAT AS
PART OF THE BUDGET ACT NEXT
YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE ON THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS OKAY SAYING NO
COMMENTS WILL BE REMOVED SB.
EIGHT THREE ONE. HELLO. A GOOD
MORNING CAROLINE CHU FROM
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SB
EIGHT EIGHT THIRTY ONE EXPANDS
THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT IN PARTICULAR- AS
YOU MAY RECALL THE BUDGET ACT
PASSED EARLIER THIS YEAR PASSED
UP A FORTY EIGHT YEAR EXCUSE ME
EXPANDED THE CALIFORNIA YEAH I.
T. C. CHIU FILERS WITH
INDIVIDUAL TAX IDENTIFICATION
NUMBERS WHO HAD CHILDREN SIX
YEARS OR YOUNGER THE- AND THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL WOULD
FURTHER EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
HEARING TO SEE TO ALL AYE TEN
FILERS WHO HAVE ELIGIBLE INCOME.
THANK YOU FINANCE. GOOD MORNING
J. CHAMBERLAND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I HAVE
OF I REALLY HAVE NOTHING TO ADD
ABOUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU HI MISTER MONTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR UP PROBABLY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
UNLIKE OTHER ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS EITC DEPENDS ON THE
EXISTENCE OF EARNED INCOME AND-
THE QUESTION IS- JUST WHAT THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD BE ABLE TO-
WITH ONLY AND I TEN AND NOT A
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER VERIFY
THAT THE- THAT THE EARNED
INCOME EXISTS. IF A QUESTION
ARISES AROUND ELIGIBILITY. YES
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION. YES IT
AND HANDLE SENSUALLY IN ALL
CASES THEY WILL HAVE THE SAFETY
ABILITY TO VERIFY THE INCOME
AND THERE WILL BE SOME
DIFFICULTIES- IN PARTICULAR%
CASES IF A TAXPAYER HASN'T.
HASN'T MADE CROSS FILE RETURN
FOR THE PAST COUPLE YEARS AND
DOES NOT HAVE A WAGE INCOME
THAT CASE. FRANCHISE TAX WOULD
BE NEED TO DO SOME ADDITIONAL-
OF VERIFICATION OF INCOME WHICH
IS WHY WE HAVE LANGUAGE IN
THERE THEY THEY CAN SEND THAT
OUT ABILITY TO. TO ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL- ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION HOWEVER A WE DO
THINK THAT THAT IS THAT'S CAN
BE A REAL MINORITY OF CASES
REPORTED THEY WOULD NEED TO DO
THAT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. AND
LASTLY NOT A QUESTION MOREOF A
COMMENT THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF
BILLS THAT FALLS INTO THE
CATEGORY OF SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED. FOR YEARS HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE BUT I THINK
IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE THAT WE ARE
INTRODUCING IT FIRST OF ALL IN
BUDGET FORM. BUT SECOND OF ALL-
AS AN AMENDMENT TO A BILL THREE
DAYS BEFORE THE END OF THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION ONE THERE
IS NO CHANCE FOR US TO HAVE A
DELIBERATE OF DEBATE ABOUT IT.
THERE'S NO CHANCE FOR THE
PUBIC TO WEIGH IN ON IT- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO COST
THE STATE POTENTIALLY A LOT OF
MONEY. AND I THINK THAT WE OWE
OUR PUBLIC THE TRANSPARENCY TO
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR THE ARGUMENTS FOR AND
AGAINST IT UNFORTUNATELY THAT
TIME IS JUST NOT HERE. THANK
YOU. COMMENTS DR ED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I AM GLAD TO
SEE S. B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE COME
BEFORE US TODAY BECAUSE IT'S A
SIGNAL FROM OUR STATE THAT WE
ANSWERED THE CALL FROM OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES FOR US
TO INVEST IN EQUITY AND TO
PURPOSELY MOVE AWAY FROM
POLICIES THAT INADVERTENTLY. OR
INTENTIONALLY CAUSE HARM THE
FULL INCLUSION OF BY TENS IN
EACH COW E. I. T. C. WILL HELP
US BALANCE THE SCALES OF
ECONOMIC JUSTICE FOR FAMILIES
WHO UP TO THIS POINT HAVE BEEN
LEFT OUT OF RECEIVING TAX
CREDITS FOR THEIR LABORS THIS
WILL PUT MONEY BACK INTO THE
POCKETS ESPECIALLY AT A TIME
WHEN IT IS MOST NEEDED AND THIS
WILL BE A WELCOME RELIEF AS
THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST IF NOT
THE BEST ANTI POVERTY PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU DOCTOR AND I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST. CLARIFY WE
HAVE DONE. A NUMBER OF. EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT EXPANSIONS
OVER THE LAST. NUMBER OF YEARS
AND THEY'VE ALL BEEN DONE
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET PROCESS I
YEAH I DO APPRECIATE MY BY OUR
FOSTER'S COMMENTS THAT- THE
TRADITIONALLY WERE DONE IN JUNE
THIS ONE IS DONE OUT LATER IN
THE YEAR. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
GO BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES- JUST GOING BACK TO MY
VOICE OUR PROVIDERS QUESTION.
IS DO YOU ANTICIPATE ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SELF EMPLOYED THAT'S WHERE
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE GONNA FIND
POTENTIAL ISSUES. DO YOU WANT
TO DO YOU'LL IDENTIFY ANY MORE
DIFFICULTY IDENTIFYING INCOME
THAN ANY OTHER SELF EMPLOYED
INDIVIDUALS. I. ALL IN MOST
CASES PROBABLY NOT- I'M I I'M
ACTUALLY TO HAVE A HARD TIME
RIGHT NOW THINKING OF WHAT-
WHAT THE DIFFICULTY MIGHT BE- I
THINK- YEAH I THINK FOR SELF
EMPLOYED I THINK YOU YOU KNOW
WHETHER YOU WHETHER YOU'RE SELF
EMPLOYED WITH AND I TEN. OR
WITH A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
ARE THERE WOULD BE A NEED TO
GET SOME SORT OF ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTATION. FROM THE
TAXPAYER TO VERIFY THAT THE
THAT THEY REALLY DOWNTURN THAT
INCOME. I JUST IMAGINE THAT YOU
WE MUST HAVE MILLIONS I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER OF THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO.
SELF REPORT INCOME MEANING THEY
DON'T GET A W. TWO. LIKE THOSE
OF US WHO ARE EMPLOYEE PLEASE-
AND THAT THE- BOARD. HAS A
FAIRLY EXTENSIVE PROCESS HOW
WOULD VERY. THAT INCOME. FOR
ALL OF THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE SELF
REPORTING INCOME. THAT'S
CORRECT NOT TO MENTION THE BEEN
DOING THAT FOR DECADES. WELL I
THINK SENT CEASE AND SEE-
CREATION OF THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT THEY HAVE ME-
TYPICALLY. IT'S IN THE SENSE
IT'S REFUNDABLE CREDIT IT'S
MORE OPEN TO- TO IMPROPER
PAYMENTS- AS OPPOSED TO JUST
OFFSETTING TAX SO I THINK
THERE'S BEEN A HEIGHTENED
EFFORT HAD VERIFIED THAT INCOME
SENSE- WE CREATED THE INCOME
TAX CREDIT. GOT A SO YOU'RE
YOU'RE ACCESSING THAT THE
FRANCHISE TAX PROPOSED SPENDS
MORE TIME VERIFYING. THESE
INDIVIDUALS INCOMES AND THEY
WOULD A TYPICAL TAXPAYER THAT
IS MINOR YES I CAN'T I'M NOT
CERTAIN OF THAT BUT THAT'S
UNDERSTANDING HER OKAY THANK
YOU. ANY OF. ALL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS IF NOT LET'S MOVE TO
SB. EIGHT THREE TWO. CAROLYN
CHILDREN FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE S. B. AT EIGHT
THIRTY TWO WOULD AFFECT THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION PROTECTS
THE VALUE OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
HOME IN THE EVENT OF BANKRUPTCY.
AT THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE
THAT PROTECTION TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR THE
MEDIAN SALE PRICE OF A HOME IN
THAT COUNTY. I WITH A CAP OF
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
THE BILL ALSO WOULD ADDRESS
THESE AMOUNTS- FOR INFLATION
GOING FORWARD. BUT THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU TO PROVIDE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- NO
FURTHER COMMENTS BUT HAPPY
ANSWER QUESTIONS. QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MISTER
ROGERS. ALL RIGHT I HAVE TO ASK
A LAST THE L. A. O. SINCE
YOU'RE THE ONES PRESENTING THE
BILL UP WHAT ON EARTH DOES THIS
HAVE TO DO WITH THE BUDGET. IT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING SIR THAT
THIS IS A TRAILER BILL THE
BUDGET DOES CONTAIN. VARIOUS
PROTECTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
RELATED TO THE- RELATED TO COPE
IT- AND PROVIDES. EXPANSION OF
ECONOMIC PROTECTIONS. THAT WE
WERE NOT INVOLVED IN THE-
CRAFTING OF THIS LEGISLATION SO
I WOULD BE. REFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
FURTHER DETAILS. ALL RIGHT ALL
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHAT ON EARTH DOES THIS HAVE TO
DO WITH THE BUDGET. YES CRISCO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT AS THE L. A. O.
DID THAT THIS HAS A NEXUS WITH
KOBE TO PROVIDE SOME
PROTECTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS-
WHO WHO MAY BE FORCED FIVE.
INTO BANKRUPTCY- DUE TO KOBE
HARDSHIPS. WELL I WOULD JUST
ALSO ADDED THIS IS A
LEGISLATIVE REQUEST AND SO AS
TO THE DETAILS ABOUT THIS I
HAVE NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD.
OKAY WELCOME. ME THE ASSERTION
THAT ANYTHING WITH THE NEXUS TO
COVE IT AUTOMATICALLY BECOMES
BUDGET RELATED I THINK IS
RIDICULOUS. BUT I MEAN
NORMALLY. BUDGET TRAILER BILLS
ARE. OF SCORES OF PAGES LONG
THIS IS A COUPLE OF SENTENCES.
I ORDINARILY WHEN WE TRY TO
CALL SOMETHING A BUDGET BILL WE
AT LEAST PUT A TOKEN
APPROPRIATION IN THERE SO WE
CAN LEAVE OUR HANDS AND SAY.
WELL LOOK IT'S RELATED THE
BUDGET THIS DOESN'T EVEN HAVE
THAT SO. AGAIN I AM BITTERLY.
THAT A WEIGHTY POLICY ISSUE
LIKE THIS IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT. ON THE
CREDIT MARKETS IN CALIFORNIA IS
BEING SHOE HORNED INTO
SOMETHING MORE CALLING A BUDGET
BILL. AT THE VERY LAST MINUTE
PUT INTO PRINT ON FRIDAY THREE
DAYS BEFORE THE END OF SESSION.
BEING HEARD HERE IN BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THE DAY BEFORE THE
END OF SESSION THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TRANSPARENCY IT'S SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS PUBLIC DEBATE. IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE OUGHT TO
BE SURE RUNNING THROUGH THE
LAST MINUTE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A GOOD
IDEA FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT.
AND IT COMMENTS. YEAH LIKE
AGAIN I THINK MY BY SURE MAKES
A VERY FAIR POINT I BELIEVE AS
OUR L. A. O. ON ARTICULATED
THIS IS JUST ABOUT PROVIDING-
VERY MODEST- PROTECTIONS FOR A
PARTICULAR FOR HOMEOWNERS- AND
PROPERTY OWNERS. WHO ARE RISK
OF- LOSING THEIR SINGLE FAMILY
HOME. BECAUSE OF THE FINANCIAL
CONDITIONS- GIVEN THAT THIS IS
THE END OF SESSION AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE RECESSING WE
THOUGHT WE BETTER BETTER TO
TAKE ACTION TO PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS- PARTICULAR- WE HAVE
A SEPARATE TENTATIVE ACTION
BUILT IS GOING THROUGH SEPARATE
FROM THE BUDGET PROCESS. BUT IT
DID MAKE SENSE TO TAKE A
FACTUAL FOR EVERY SENSE. SO ANY
OTHER COMMENTS DELIVERS GO TO
THE PUBLIC. WE ARE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THE PUBLIC IS OPEN TO COMMENT
ON ANY OF THE ITEMS PRESENTED
ANY PUBLIC IN FORTY TWO OH TWO
WHICH TO STEP UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. I'M NOT SEEING A
RUSH TO THE MICROPHONES SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINE MODERATE ARE YOU THERE.
PLEASE JOIN ME ON THE PHONE IF
YOU WISH TO HAVE COMMON YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. YOU'LL BE PROVIDED YOUR
LINE NUMBER WHEN YOU'RE HERE
LINE NUMBER CALLED. YOUR FREE
TO SPEAK. NOT SHOWING ANYBODY
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
I'M GONNA REPEAT THE NUMBER CAN
WE MAKE SURE IT'S FOR PUT BACK
ON THE SCREEN IT'S ON.
977-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. IF FOR ANY REASON
YOU'RE HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
ON TO THE PHONE LINE YOU CAN
CALL OUR COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE NINE WE'RE GOING TO WAIT.
THE SECOND TO SEE ANY ANY MORE
PEOPLE COMING UP OPERATOR. WE
DO HAVE SOME COMING UP NOW
PLEASE ALLOW A FEW MOMENTS
THANK YOU THEN FEEL FREE TO A
WEDNESDAY WAS THEIR QUEUED UP
TO START LETTING THEM ON
EVERYBODY GETS ONE MINUTE. YOU
ONCE AGAIN GET YOUR LINE NUMBER
FROM THE OPERATOR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY TWO FIVE TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS JOHN
AND I'M WITHOUT SOMEONE AYE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FEDERAL AT
THE NUMBER OF THE CALL EITC
COALITION I SUPPORT SB EIGHT
THREE ONE AND FOLLOW INCLUSION
IN THE CALI ITEP. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE MORE THAT
ARE QUEUING UP I'M NOT SEEING
ANY LINE NUMBERS ON MY SCREEN
YET ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE MAY BE
HAVING TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
ON OUR OTHER END ONE MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY ONE FOR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS BY MICHAEL MILLER THE
COMPANY'S DECISION WHEN GREAT
POWERS WE ARE OPPOSED TO. SB
EIGHT FIFTEEN ON THE PROVISION
RELATED TO- FARMWORKER HOUSING.
THE BILL CONTINUES TO PROVIDE
FOR DISCRIMINATION HOUSING
BASED ON IMMIGRATION STATUS AND
ACTION MAKES THE WORST BECAUSE-
ANY GAUGE TO WAIT FOR YOUR IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO EMPLOYS NINE H.
TWO EIGHT EMPLOYEES. THAT MEANS
THAT THOSE WORKERS ARE NO
LONGER ELIGIBLE FOR THAT
HOUSING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AS FOR NOBLE IN THE BILL. AND
WATER LINE NUMBER NINETY THREE
NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS INSTANT WERE AT LARGE
WITH ONE GROUP ON BEHALF YOU
STICK COMMUNITY ENERGY HE SAID
HE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SB ONE FIFTEEN
SPECIFICALLY SECTION EIGHTEEN.
WITH THE ALLOCATION TO THE
CHEAT SHEET FOR AT EIGHT
ELECTRICAL CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO JUST A MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA LINE
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JAKE MURPHY ON BEHALF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA- WE'RE
OPPOSED TO- SECTION THIRTY ONE.
SB EIGHT TWENTY THE EDUCATION-
BUDGET TRAILER BILL WE BELIEVE
THAT SECTION THIRTY ONE GREAT
AND I'M NOT VERY NEW STATUTES
REVOCATION PROP THAT THE
CAPITULATE TO DELAYS IN THE
APPROVAL OF UT CAPITAL
PROJECTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER MEMBERS MONICA GELLER ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
MONEY ACK. WE ARE GREATLY. YOU
SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK DONE WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THIS
IS GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED AND
WHILE THE ADVOCACY. COMMUNITY
IT HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION. WE
HAD A GOOD FRAMEWORK IN PLACE
PRIOR TO THE END AND- LEAVE
THAT WITH A WORKABLE SOLUTION
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE TO WORK UPON
COMPLETION. I'M NOT COUNTY THAT
GET THE MOST FOR THEIR HOPPER.
ARE YOU CONNECTED AND THEN GO
BACK YEAH WHEN ABOUT THIS WHAT
THANK YOU. THANK WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN. THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS JANET AREA SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL AID AT WORK
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS LOW WAGE WORKING
FAMILIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTY Q. AB EIGHTY TO
PROVIDE THE ESSENTIAL
PROTECTION ENSURE THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
FIRST APPEAL TO GAPING HOLES IN
THE FEDERAL FAMILY FIRST
PROVIDES RESPONSE FACT THAT
LEAVES. OUT UP TO TWELVE
MILLION CALIFORNIA WORKERS. AND
SECOND TO ADDRESS SMALL
BUSINESS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. THAT THE GREAT THE FIRST
pOF ITS KIND SMALL EMPLOYER
FAMILY LEAVE MEDIATION PILOT
PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HAS BEEN. UNDER THIS
PROGRAM SMALL EMPLOYERS
UNVEILED THE REQUEST FREE
MEDIATION BEFORE EMPLOYEES
ALLOWED TO FILE A LAWSUIT IN
COURT IT CREATES A UNIQUE
AVENUE EARLY RESOLUTION OF ANY
FAMILY LEAVE ISSUES THAT MAY
ARISE BETWEEN SMALL EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES. IF THE TYPICALLY
ADDRESSES THE CONCERN ABOUT
POTENTIAL LITIGATION FOR
ENVIRONMENT ON COMPLIANCE FOR
SMALL EMPLOYERS WITHOUT
DEDICATED HR DEPARTMENT.
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM THE SMALL
EMPLOYERS WILL NOW HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE ANY
INADVERTENT VIOLATIONS PRIOR TO
INCURRING ANY LITIGATION COSTS.
THESE PROVISIONS LIKE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE ARE
CENTRAL TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
CO THE NINETEEN AND PUT AN END
TO THIS CRISIS. NOW THE TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA TO ACT TO ENSURE
THE HEALTH ECONOMIC SECURITY
AND WELL BEING OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE.
PANDEMIC AND BEYOND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE NUMBER
NINETY NINE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT THANK YOU HI THIS IS
CLARK JOHNSON ROBERT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
CONSUMER LAW CLINIC SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THIRTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF OUR LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNER CLIENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
PARTICULARLY ARE SENIOR
CITIZENS WHO NEED TO COME AT
EXEMPTION. THANK. THANK YOU A
GROWING NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ALEX IT CAPRI ON BEHALF
OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY LEAVE
MEDIATION PILOT PROGRAM UNDER
SB EIGHT TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND YOUR CHAIR JUST
WHAT YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE SIXTY
CURRENTLY IN QUEUE THE QUEUE UP
TO HAVE A COMMON JUST TO GIVE
YOU AN ESTIMATE. WELL NUMBER
ONE NUMBER NINE EIGHT NINE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS JEFF ABOUT GLOBAL
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. CALLING IN SUPPORT OF.
THE REPEAL. OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FEES. CANADA GROCERY
ALSO IN SUPPORT- ENDING THE
EXCLUSION OF WORKERS WITH I CAN
NUMBERS. AT REFORM IN THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND MODERNIZING
THE ON EXTENSION THANK YOU.
WELL NUMBER ONE NUMBER NINETY
SEVEN NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN JUST TO CLARIFY YOU SAID
SIXTY RIGHT SIX ZERO. SIX ZERO
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINETY SEVEN YOU CAN GO.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN GOLDSTINE
WITH THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WE SPEAK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY THREE FOR NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS WE'VE MONITORED ON GOING
TO PIECES AT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
AND WE'VE ALSO DELIVERED
COMMUNITY SERVICES FOR
DETECTING ELIGIBLE U. S. B.
TWENTY THREES TIMELY IT'S
RESPONSIBLE AND IT THAT
SUPPORTS YOUNG PEOPLE. WE STAND
READY WITH OTHER SERVICE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE TO
PARTNER WITH COUNTIES AND
REALIGN TEACHER DURING THE
RIGHT WAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL RELY NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT TO THREE THE SHIFT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE POPULATION
THAT COUNTY. OUTCOMES FOR THESE
YOUTH WERE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
OUR NEGOTIATIONS WE DO THINK WE
CAN IMPROVE THE STATE CURRENT
OUTCOMES WITH THE VIEW UNDER
THE RIGHT CONDITIONS AND WOULD
LOVE TO FURTHER DISCUSS SOME OF
THE TYPICAL COMMENTS IN TODAY'S
HEARING. THIS PROPOSAL WILL NOT
GET EACH COUNTY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
AND WE ARE NOT SAYING THIS IS
AN IMPLEMENTABLE WITHOUT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR. SB EIGHT TO THREE ABOUT
FIXING THE STATE OUTCOMES WITH
THE STATE PROGRAM IS BEING
SHIFTED TO COUNTY BECAUSE OF
THE SUCCESS OF COUNTY
LEADERSHIP WITH OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS WE REGRET OUR POSITION
AND HOPE FOR MORE FRUITFUL
DISCUSSIONS IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RELY
NUMBER FORTY SIX FOUR SIX ZERO
ONE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
DANIEL SANCHEZ WITH THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER TO CREDIBLY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE E. TWENTY
THREE THIS REALIGNMENT
REPRESENTS A VERY LARGE AND
COMPLEX POLICY ISSUE WITH
SIGNIFICANT IMPLICATIONS FOR
THE NUCLEAR CARE. AND WE HAD WE
HAD TESTIFIED THAT COSBY SHOULD
SHE HAVE PUSH FOR SIGNIFICANT
REFORMS. HAVE LED TO THE
IMPROVEMENT IN THE LIVES OF THE
U. CREATURE IT IS THEIR
LEADERSHIP THAT IS WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS TO YOU BEST
PRACTICES TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND WE WANT TO
DO THAT HERE. I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT PROVISION IS NOT
OPPOSED TO OVERSIGHT OUR
CONCERN IS THIS BILL SIMPLY
BUILD THE LAYERS OF STATE
BUREAUCRACY THAT DOESN'T WORK
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE MANY
LAYERS OF OVERSIGHT IN THE
SYSTEM. WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THE APPROACHING EACH TWENTY
THREE ON OUR ABILITY TO DESIGN
AND DEPLOY THE SENATE
RESPONSIVE AND INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS CONTINUE TO SUPPORT.
AND ADVANCE PUBLIC PATHWAYS AND
OUTCOMES FOR ALL YOU. TO BE
SHOULD FEEL THE DEEPEST. TO
EVERY YOUTH IN OUR CARE AND IT
IS FOR THOSE REASONS THAT WE
WOULD BE REMISS IF WE DID NOT
RAISE THE ISSUE THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL HAVE UNINTENDED IMPACT ON
THE OUTCOME FOR ALL YOU. LOOK
FOR THE MARKET CONVERSATION AND
REGRETTABLY ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE E. TWENTY THREE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO.
NUMBER FIFTY. ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KATHY SURE
FOR THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE. AFTER
DECADES OF ABUSE AND FAILURE AT
DJJ WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
CLOSES DJJ THE RIGHT WAY. BY
PROVIDING ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT OF
COUNTY SYSTEMS SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE WILL WORK TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR USE BY MAKING SURE
THEY GET THE SERVICES THEY NEED
WHILE REMAINING CLOSE TO HOME.
AGAIN WE CALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB. EIGHT TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU WOULD ALIGN NUMBER
SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS THAT THIS IS
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AT EIGHT
FIFTEEN- THAT AT THE OUTLINE
WITH ON H. TWO A. FARMWORKER
HOUSING- UNFORTUNATELY- THE AS
WE UNDERSTAND IT THE AG
INDUSTRY. NEVER SEE CAN YOU
REACH OUT TO DISCUSS LANGUAGE
WE WERE CRIED AT THE LANGUAGE
WENT WENT ON A DIFFERENT ON
FRIDAY. AND WE ARE VERY
DISAPPOINTED COULD YOU JUST BE-
THIS CONTINUED EFFORT TO
DISCRIMINATE ON HOUSING BASED
ON IMMIGRATION STATUS- SO WE
URGE. A NO VOTE ON SB EIGHT
FIFTEEN. WE'LL GET A LINE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NICOLE
WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION TO AT EIGHT TWENTY
THREE THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT. THIS
REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL DOES NOT
INCORPORATE INPUT FROM THE
INTERNET ENTITIES TO PROVIDE
CARE CUSTODY AND REHABILITATION
OF YOUTH CASES. IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT TIME TO
PREPARE LOCAL PROGRAMS AND
FACILITIES AND- THE STAFF WHICH
IS A BRAND NEW STATE OFFICE AND
GROWTH THE NEW OFFICE
CONSIDERABLE CONTROL OVER
EXISTING LOCAL PROGRAM. WE ARE
JUST IN THE- HOWEVER WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
WALK INTO THE FUTURE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A LITTLE
AYE NUMBER FORTY FIVE FOUR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR KAREN MEMBER MIKE
AT DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT Q. FOUR
I'M ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF A
NEW WAY OF LIFE ALL OF US ARE
NOT AND- ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION EAST BAY COMMUNITY
LAW CENTER. ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS HOMEBOY THE
INDUSTRY'S AND TAKE TEN ARE FOR
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN THE POLICY
LANGUAGE. SAN FRANCISCO
FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER
WESTERNCENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND THE THEFT OF
COALITION THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
BELT. THANK YOU GROWING NUMBER
NINETY TWO NINE TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIELLE CANDLE CARDS
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT SB.
EIGHT THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU
WOULD LNE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
TO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB
GOOD AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS JOHN
LEVEL IN A TESTIFIED ON BEHALF
OF ALCOHOL MONITORING SERVICES-
ON SEVERAL OTHER- GROUPS-
COMMENTING ON S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR. WE SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT THAT THE COURT SHOULD
NOT BE BURDENED DOWN WITH
VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIVE MEANS
AND WE SUPPORT THE SIXTY FIVE
MILLION THAT IS IMPORTANT THE
BUDGET. THAT'S CORRECT WE ARE
VERY VERY VERY CONCERNED. THAT
THERE ADEQUATE STRUCTURE TO
THAT SIXTY FIVE MILLION THAT
THIS WILL RESULT IN THE
DESTRUCTION OF VERY EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM THAT ARE ALTERNATIVE
CULTURE RIGHT. FOR EXAMPLE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SOBRIETY
PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE A
REMARKABLE- SUCCESS RATE IN
CHANGING BEHAVIOR AND IN
DEALING WITH RECIDIVISM IN
CONNECTION WITH HER FIVE GLOBAL
OPTIONS OUT THERE WILL BE AN-
WITH THE MESSAGE WILL BE USED.
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SIX SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THE REGULAR OF MINE
WITH THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
YOUTH LAW. I'M ALSO I'M A
FILMMAKER HERE YOU NOW YOUTH
ADVOCATE AND I'M SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF XP EIGHT
TWENTY THREE DDG REALIGNMENT.
SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE CREEK
MENTAL STATE OVERSIGHT OF
RELYING JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND BACK IN EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES CONSERVING YOU HI
NEED ACTIVATING TRANSCRIPTION
THAT COULD HAVE YOU COULD YOU
DON'T GIVE THEM. A LARGE
MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE YOU
CALLER FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS. AND I URGE YOU NOT
TO BELIEVE THE FALSE
INFORMATION CIRCULATED BY
OPPONENTS TO MISLEAD YOU EIGHT
BACK TAKE TWENTY THREE THANKS
FOR REGARD TO COUNTY TO ENSURE
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE
TO THE COSTLY. STATE CREDITED
THEM BUT IT ALSO PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
NOT BE ACTED. STATE MUST
PROVIDE ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT OF
OVER TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO COUNTIES TO PROVIDE
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMMING SERVICES
TO FIT THE VOLUME. BUT COMPLEX
NEEDS OR OVERWHELMINGLY LOW
INCOME YOUTH OF COLOR WE URGE
YOUR. APPLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A LINE OF NINETY. NOW SX
ZERO ONE OPEN. I NINETY SIX
CHECK YOUR LINE FOR SELF MUTE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
NOT COOPERATING ON BEHALF OF
MUD AND THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY- WELL ON THE
PART OF SB ONE ONE FIVE BUT THE
GRAVY INCREASE FUNDING FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE BC. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GUILDERLAND
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED ONE ZERO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND HAPPY WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES A MEMBER OF THE
EDUCATION EQUITY COALITION
COMMENTING AND EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL SB EIGHT TWENTY ID
LIKE TO THANK THE MEMBERS AND
STAFF THE ADMINISTRATION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
ALLEY- FOR YOUR DILIGENT. WELL
WE APPRECIATE MUCH OF THE
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN SB EIGHT
TWENTY WE URGE YOU TO REJECT
THE PROPOSED CHANGE TO THE
AUDIT GUIDE WHICH WOULD
DRAMATICALLY LIMIT THE SCOPE OF
SCHOOL DISTRICT AUDIT AND
GREATLY REDUCE THE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN DISTANCE
LEARNING THAT WAS ADOPTED IN
THE GYM BUDGET. WE ALSO
RECOMMEND ENACTING MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION THE SCHOOL YEAR TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT DISPARITY
IN THE AMOUNT OF LIVE
INSTRUCTION OFFERED IN
DISTRICTS PROVIDING DISTANCE
LEARNING LASTLY WE RECOMMEND
EXTENDING THE DEADLINE PROVIDES
THE LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN BUDGET
OVERVIEW FOR PARENTS TEMPLATE
AND INSTRUCTIONS. UNTIL OCTOBER
FIFTEENTH TO ALLOW SUFFICIENT
TIME TO CONSULT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND APPLYING THE
TEMPLATE TO THE LEARNING
CONTINUITY INATTENDANCE PLAN
ADOPTED THIS YEAR PLEASE REFER
TO THE EQUITY COALITIONS AUGUST
TWENTY FIFTH LETTER FOR
DETAILED INFORMATION ON A
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. WILL I NUMBER SIXTEEN ONE
SIX ZERO ONE IS OPEN. SH MY
ANGER ACLU OF CALIFORNIA I
ALIGN MY COMPANY LEGAL AID AT
WORK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TO
TWO BECAUSE THE PROVIDE SUPPORT
TO SMALL EMPLOYERS WHILE
ENSURING THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS
WHO WORK FOR THEM CAN TAKE THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE THEY PAY FOR
WITHOUT RISKING THEIR JOBS. I
ALSO EXPRESSED THE SUPPORT OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA FOR
SB EIGHT TWO TWO AND ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
THREE ONE TO BOLSTER HE
ECONOMIC SECURITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT FAMILY.
THANK YOU. GABELEIN NUMBER
SIXTY NINE SIX NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. KAREN MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM ADDED ON WITH
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
SECTION CALIFORNIA NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
THE EIGHT THIRTY ONE THE
EXPANSION OF CALLIE I KEEP
SPEAKS TO ALL I AM FILERS NOW
MORE THAN EVER WE NEED
INVESTMENTS FOR THE LONG TERM
THAT WILL BOOST LOCAL ECONOMIES
PROTECT ALL OF CALIFORNIANS
WORKERS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
ADDRESS STRUCTURE. STRUCTURAL
INEQUITIES IN OUR TAX SYSTEM
THAT CURRENTLY ACTIVATED
EQUALITY FOR IMMIGRANT WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE. TO SUPPORT AT
THE EIGHT THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE LINE NUMBER
NINETY FIVE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN IN
SCOPE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IS
STRONG BY NETWORK OF S. B.
EIGHT THREE ONE AND S. B. EIGHT
TWO TWO THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND ONE
ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ELIZABETH HAS BEEN A FROM
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD CUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA I
WANT TO LARGELY ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY SEA
FACT AND THE PROBATION CHIEFS
BEFORE MEETING- BUT ALSO TO
REITERATE THATCOUNTY'S BROADLY
SPEAKING. ARE ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO ASSESSING WAYS TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. WE ARE SEEING THE
BENEFITS OF KEEPING A CLOSE TO
HOME AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT DESIGNING A NEW
SYSTEM THAT WILL RESULT. IN
INCREASED ADULT COURT
COMMITMENTS I THINK WE SHARE
THOSE GOALS WITH THE ADVOCATES
AND WHAT'S UP MANY OF THE
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
THE EXPRESSION OF OPPOSITION
TODAY THAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM
COUNTIES IN PROBATION CHIEF IS
DIRECTLY TIED TO CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE WORKABILITY OF S. B.
EIGHT TWO THREE AS IT'S DRAFTED
AND WHETHER THE PROMISE OF
BETTER OUTCOMES IN THE PROPOSED
THREE DESIGN STRUCTURE CAN BE
DELIVERED. WE STAND READY TO
WORK JOINTLY TO ASSESS AND
RESOLVE THESE CONCERNS- BECAUSE
AS IT STANDS TODAY WE ARE
NERVOUS THAT THEY WILL HAMPER
OUR ABILITY TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE PEOPLE IN OUR CARE AND
WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT IF WE
CLOSE DJJ. WE CLOSE IT THE
RIGHT WAY AND WE DON'T BELIEVE
WE'RE BEING GIVEN THE TOOLS TO
SUCCEED. IN THE PROVISIONS OF
SB EIGHT TO THREE THANK YOU.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
OUR PERSPECTIVES. THANK YOU
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWO ONE ZERO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WEARING
STRONG STRONGLY SUPPORTED AT
THE EIGHT THREE ONE HE'LL
EXPAND THE CALLIE ITC ALL
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. I'M I'M
ALSO HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
ALONG WITH A FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION AT B. EIGHT TWO
THREE WE BELIEVE THAT OBJECT OF
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
OF THIS GIVEN OBJECT IT'S
REALIGNMENT IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR YOU. AND
WE'RE ALSO AT THE PORT IF YOU
ORGANIZATIONS AT SB EIGHT TO
FOUR- ON CRIMINAL. BABY THANK
YOU. YOUR GIRL I NUMBER FIFTY
NINE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN
RODRIGUEZ MEANING OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS WE SUPPORT SB ONE
ONE FIVE PACIFIC LEE SECTION
EIGHTEEN ABOUT BILL AND THE
FACT THAT PUT THE TO THE
ALTERNATIVE AND RENEWABLE FUEL
AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY FUND. TO
SUPPORT ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA EBT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM AT THE
CDC THANK YOU. GUILDERLAND
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR TWO FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED MEMBERS DISAGREE FAIR
AND THE DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION
IN PUBLIC NOT THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER AT ORANGE COUNTY
WE'RE EXPECTING STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB EIGHT THIRTY TWO. THE
GREAT RECESSION COMING INCOME
HOMEOWNERS BUT EXPERIENCED
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES WITH THEIR
DEATH AND WHERE AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR HOMES BECAUSE OF
CALIFORNIANS OUTDATED HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION. BUT THE UPCOMING
EXPECTED FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
FOR MANY IF NOT ALL OF MY
CLIENTS THE TIME IS RIGHT TO
PROTECT. CALIFORNIA HOME THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WILL I NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CATHERINE LIVE ORDERED
PRESIDENT OF AFTER THE THIRTY
TWO NINETY NINE REPRESENTING
UC'S SERVICE WORKERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT TWENTY. THANK YOU.
BOTH YOU WILL AYE NUMBER. SIXTY
FOUR SIX FOUR ZERO. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS THOUGHT HE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. I SUPPORT
THE REALIGNMENT CLOTHING BJJ
THE RIGHT WAY WHERE MEMBERS
EACH YEAR THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HAVE INTERGENERATIONAL
TRAUMA I WILL BE LEADERS IN THE
ONE BREAKING CYCLES AND THEIR
FAMILIES THE CLOSER TO HOME
WITH THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
MENTAL MATTERS SB EIGHTY THREE
IS A PATH TO A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY YOUTH JUSTICE MODELS
THE STRONG FOUNDATION IN THE
WELL ESTABLISHED RESEARCH IN
SCIENCE FOR YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND YOU GUYS
ENJOY THE REST YOUR DAY. THANK
YOU WITH A LINE THIRTY ONE
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BRIAN
LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE H. TWO A.
EMPLOYEE HOUSING PROVISIONS OF
S. B. EIGHT ONE FIVE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR LOGO
AND ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF. MR MILLER WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL MIGRATE
GROWERS MR ALAN. WITH WESTERN
GROWERS PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU.
WELL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SIX ONE ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE ROOFTOP ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIFTEEN
OF THE BECKLEY SECTION TWENTY
WHICH PROVIDES TRANSIT AGENCY
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ORDER LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THREE ONE ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
RESTAURANT IS A TRUE THOUGH THE
COALITION PREMIUM YOUR RIGHTS
AND STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
FOLLOWING BILLS. SB EIGHT TO
FOUR SB. EIGHT THREE ONE AND SB
EIGHT THREE TWO THANK YOU I
NUMBER FIFTY FOUR FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS TAMMY NO NEAR THEM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FATHERS
AND FAMILIES OF SAN JOAQUIN
LOCATED IN STOCKTON CALIFORNIA
AND A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
NINE THREE THINK COMMUNITY
JUSTICE AND COMMON IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTEEN CREEK
CODE BJJ THE RIGHT WAY. AND THE
COMMUNITY WILL ONE OF THE STATE
FACILITIES LOCATED IN A REGION
WHERE MANY OF THE FACILITIES AT
THE PLANT CARE. AND DONE.
AGENCY TO LOOK ON THE FRONT
LINE. YOUNG PEOPLE THE- ON MANY
TEND TO DISPLAY FROM THE BAY
AREA COMMUNITIES. YEAH THAT
STEP IN AND TOOK THE YOUNG. ARE
WE BELIEVE THAT A TO DO WITH
THE COULD FIRST STEP TO PROVIDE
INTERNET TO. OVER TWO MOVED TO
HELP YOU COULD. FOR THE
NEGATIVE I WAS THE TRAUMA
BECAUSE CENTER WE THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTEE CENTRIC EVEN PRACTICE
CAN HAVE ONE ARE YOU. FAMILIES
AND THE COMMITTED ALL. REPORT
SB. EIGHT TWO THREE. THANK YOU
WILL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHT ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS CUT THEM BACK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALLING
INTO FOUR OF SB EIGHT TWENTY
TWO. ALL MY COMMON LEGAL AID AT
WORK AND JUST NOTE THAT THE-
SMALL EMPLOYER FAMILY B. E. DH
AND PILOT PROGRAM AND THE-
PROVISION OF PAID SICK DAYS
PAID LEAVE CAN BE ESSENTIAL FOR
WORKERS. ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. WELL I NUMBER THIRTY
THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE STAFF APPRECIATE YOUR
TAKING THE TIME TO CONNECT WITH
THIS YEAR. MY NAME IS THEN PUT
A LITTLE ON THE- MY COMMENTS
ARE RELATIVE DENSITY ONE
FIFTEEN BUT PEOPLE JUNIOR ON
BEHALF OF AUDUBON CALIFORNIA
ASSUME ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA RELIEF IN THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY. ON STRONG
SUPPORTER THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
INVOLVING LOAN TO BE PAID IN
DUE TIME TO ENSURE THAT HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION IS AVAILABLE FOR
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER ON IN THIS FISCAL YEAR.
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS OF A LACK OF ACCESS
TO CLEAN WATER FOR MANY OF THE
MOST MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
IN STATE SPECIALLY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC THAT WORLD IMPROVE.
ALL THE ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALSO
SUPPORTED THE EXPLORATION OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN EXISTING BOND FUNDS
FOR NATURAL RESOURCE PROJECTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU WILL I NEVER SIXTY FIVE SIX
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS LAURIE PERSON FILED
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT TWENTY TWO ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWENTY
WHILE ASKING FOR THE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENT. WORKING PARENTS AND
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS ARE RISKING
THEIR LIVES SO MANY OF US HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING FROM
HOME TO MINIMIZE THEIR EXPOSURE
TO THE PANDEMIC. BLACK AND
BROWN FAMILIES AND PEOPLE WITH
THE FEWEST RESOURCES INTO
PARKER CARRYING OUR COMMUNITIES
HEAVIEST BURDENS THAT DIFFICULT
TIME. FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
THAT THE BILL WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS TO
COVER YOUR COSTS OF CARE FOR
SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN. TO HELP
INSURE APPF WILL NOT NEED TO
START ROLLING FAMILY TERM
STATEMENT AFTER CHILD CARE
BEGINNING IN OCTOBER. WHICH
WOULD HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON FAMILIES PROVIDERS AND OUR
ECONOMY. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
SCHOOLS WERE ALLOCATED SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW FEDERAL
TERROR FUNDING FOR WE OPENING
COSTS. WITH MANY OF THESE COSTS
CURRENTLY PER PHONE WE URGE THE
BILL TO DIRECT THAT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO MAKE
IT ALLOWABLE FOR ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM YOUR REQUEST
REIMBURSEMENT FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOR PAYMENTS MADE TO
PROVIDERS. WHO ARE SERVING
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AND
SUPPORTING THEIR DISTANCE
LEARNING. WE ALSO ASKED TO
EXTEND ITS MENTION OF FAMILY
FEUD FOR WORKING PARENTS HE DID
NOT HAVE THE OPTION TO STAY
HOME TO SUPPORT THEIR
CHILDREN'S LEARNING AT HOME. WE
ALSO ASK THAT THE BILL DEFENDER
REQUIREMENT THAT PARENTS SIGN
ATTENDANCE SHEETS WITH OUT THE
EXTRA CONDITION THAT PROVIDERS
LACK AFTER. BRITISH SIGNATURE
AND DOCUMENT THEIR EFFORTS IN
ORDER NOT TO NEEDLESSLY EXPOSED
FAMILIES TO COPE IN NINETEEN
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDERS ARE TO
BE. PAID REGARDLESS OF
ATTENDANCE. LASTLY WE ACT THE
BILL. LANGUAGE FOR. CALIFORNIA
THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GROWING NUMBER HUNDRED TEN ONE
ZERO ZERO ONE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BURKE MY
NAME IS THAT THE CUSTOMER
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
TWO SB THREE ONE SB EIGHT TO
FOUR AND AT THE EIGHT THREE TWO
THANK YOU. WILL I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN ONE ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JULIE ON A COUPLE AND I AM
CALLING YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK BEING DONE I'M HAPPY
TWENTY PROGRAM REQUESTING- THEN
AS IT BECAME YOU. FUNDING
EXCLUSIONS FOR NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERED I AM THE PARENT
OF A STUDENT ATTENDING ACADEMY
CHARTERSCHOOL AS WELL AS THE
EMPLOYEE OF A SUCH A FULL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
ARTICLE DID NOT. EVEN QUALIFY
FOR PPP FINDING OUT THE PRODUCT
AS A SUSPECT OUR MEETING
EARLIER THIS WEEK I AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING APPROXIMATELY
A THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS THAN
WE WERE ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
NINTH BECAUSE WE HAD PREVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW PRIOR TO YOU- THE
BUDGET. BEING PASSED. EVEN
COMMITMENT THE STUDENTS TO
THIRD THEM IN EVERYTHING TO GO
BACK ON OUR WORD. ADDITIONALLY
WE A FRONT FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS WAITING TO ENROLL. I
AFTER HAVING PROVIDED AN OPEN
ACCESS LEARNING PLATFORM TO ANY
YOU KNOW WORLDWIDE DURING THE
CALL THE CAN DOWN MAKE IN
RESPONSE TO. THE NEED FOR
IMMEDIATE DISTANCE LEARNING. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THE MAJORITY OF OUR NON
PASSERBY STUDENTS ACTUALLY
ATTEND IN PERSON CLASSES AT
CAMPUSES THAN AVERAGE OF ONE TO
FIVE DAYS A WEEK. ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA JUST
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL CLASSIFIED
AS NON FLETCHER BASIS NOT BE
THERE ARE NO CLASSROOMS OR
LOCATION QUITE TO THE CONTRARY.
I URGE YOU TO FUND. ALL
STUDENTS EQUALLY THANK YOU.
WILL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN ONE ONE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
AND WHEN WE SHOULD HAVE MADE IT
THE JACKET YOU WANT AND SHALL
POPPING AND CALIFORNIA
COALITION AND WE ON STRONG
SUPPORT- AND- SB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE TO AND EXCLUSION OF I CAN
PILOT- BUT THE CHARACTER
COLLEGE THAT'S ALL I.
CALIFORNIA COALITION THANK YOU.
GILDER LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND TWELVE ONE ONE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEGAN PAPERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS CALLING TO
EXPRESS. OUR SUPPORT FOR THAT
PAID SICK LEAVE PROVISIONS IN
SB EIGHT TWENTY TWO WHAT WILL
PROVIDE FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHER
WORKERS PAID SICK LEAVE- WHO
WERE EXCLUDED FROM THE PAID
SICK LEAVE PROVISIONS OFFERED
AND I FEDERAL FAMILY FIRST ACT.
AND ALSO SUPPORT FOR SB. EIGHT
THIRTY TO THE HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LITTLE I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN TRIPLE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KATIE WATER SMITH WITH A
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
FORTUNE WE ARE IN FRONT OF PORT
SB EIGHT TWENTY TWO WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE A UNIQUE MODERNIST
MEDIATION PROGRAM FOR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE. AN EMERGENCY CASE
SIX DAYS BOTH OF WHICH ARE
ESSENTIAL TO STOPPING CREDIT
COMPANY HE THANK YOU. WELL I
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
ONE ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MARTHA'S THERE IT GOES
AGAIN IT'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND MY
COMMENT IS SPECIFIC TO SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY. PRIOR
LEGISLATION SENATE BILL NINETY
EIGHT DID NOT ESTABLISH A SET
MINIMUM SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTIONAL STANDARDS PARENTS
HAVE INFORMED US THAT
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION. VERY
FOR THEIR CHILDREN ATTENDING
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS AND IN
DIFFERENT GRADE LEVELS. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT ALL STUDENTS
RECEIVE AT LEAST A MINIMUM
AMOUNT OF SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION. WITHOUT UNIFORM
STANDARDS IN PLACE THE MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENT GROUPS PRIOR
ART PRIORITIZE THE SENATE BILL
NINETY EIGHT WILL END UP
RECEIVING SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION THAN
THEIR MORE AFFLUENT. PEERS IT
IS RECOMMENDED THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE ENACT
A MINIMUM STANDARD OF AT LEAST
THREE HOURS OF SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION. IF THIS FOLLOWS
BUT WITH THE ABILITY TO ATTRACT
AN APPROPRIATE- WITHIN ABILITY
TO ADJUST AS APPROPRIATE FOR
EARLIER GRADES THE
RECOMMENDATION FOLLOWS THE
NATIONAL BOARD. CAN
PROFESSIONAL TEACHING STANDARDS
SPECIFIC. CONSTRUCTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL. THANK YOU
OVER THE LINE NUMBERS SEVEN SO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS A- HELLO NOT
OUT I WILL SPEAKER AT THE TWO
THREE I READ. FTA LOCAL TIME
THE STATE WERE UNION WE WANT TO
MAKE ASK. THE BILL ALLOWS IF
THE COUNTRY WITH EACH OTHER BUT
NOT THE CONTRACT BACK WITH- THE
STATE OF FOR SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE U. S.
CENTER PROGRAMS THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER
MENTIONED. THESE UNITS WERE
OFTEN VICTIMS OF SEX OFFENSES
PERPETRATED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
BE CLOSE TO A FAMILY MEMBER IS
THE PROBLEM NOT THE SOLUTION.
WE ASK YOU TO KEEP THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM AT STOCKTON
BJJ THERE THE CONDOM SKL AT THE
STATE LEVEL THAT WON'T BE
AVAILABLE AT THE COUNTY OR
REGIONAL LEVEL SO WE WENT AFTER
THIS PROGRAM BE CAPPED. AT DJJ
ANSWERED ALL THE YEARS. OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. I DO
WANNA KNOW THAT WE DO HAVE A
HARD STOP ONE. I WAS IF PEOPLE
PLEASE MAY YOUR COMMENT
ASSISTING AS POSSIBLE WOULD
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOGLE I NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN ONE
ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
ONE ONE FOUR CHECK YOUR LINE
FOR SELF MUTE WE'RE HEARING THE
AUDIO. HEARING NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE ALONG TO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JAMIE
DOWN ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES RIVER STATE PARK'S
PARTNER AUDUBON CALIFORNIA THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY I DON'T WALK
YOU FACTOR ASSOCIATION LAMONT
PREVENTION INSTITUTE CLOCK SHOP
FRIEND OF THE LOS ANGELES RIVER
AT NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL BUT YOU KNOW OUTDOORS.
THREE PEOPLE WHO HAD THE LAST
YEAR AT THE COUNCIL OF MEXICAN
FEDERATION- IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPROPRIATION MEETING HAPPY ONE
FIFTEEN FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION FOR
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FOR
EXAMPLE LOCAL AGENCY BUT
OPERATING AGREEMENT THAT STATE
PARK. THE IMPORTANT THAT
OUTDOOR RECREATION AT THE TIME
TRULY CANNOT BE OVERSTATED AND
THE FUNDING WOULD HELP ENSURE
THAT EXISTING STATE PARK.
POLICE ESPECIALLY THOSE IN OR
SERVINGOTHER WORDS ARE FOR
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT LEFT. IN
THE FIRST. ERIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A LITTLE I NUMBER ONE
AND TWO TWO ONE TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THANK YOU THAT THE
ALREADY RETIRED JACKSON
CRYPTOLOGY ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND SAN MATEO
COUNTY- HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE THE DJJ REALIGNMENT
PROPOSAL. WE WOULD LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE URBAN
COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
AT THE PARK. THE BILL PLACES
ALL THE RESPONSIBILITY ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO G. PROBATION
OFFICERS WITHOUT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION OUR SUGGESTION TO
SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATE WITH
THEM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. IT
ALSO DOESN'T PROVIDE COUNTY THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT WITH
SUFFICIENT TIME TO PREPARE
LOCAL PROGRAMS AND FACILITIES
WERE CONCERNED THAT IT CREATES
A NEW STATE BUREAUCRACY IN
GRAPHIC NEW OFFICE CONSIDERABLE
CONTROL OVER GIFTING PROGRAM.
THAT HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS SO. FOR THESE REASONS
WE OPPOSE THANK YOU. GIVE A
LITTLE NUMBER HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
ONE WAY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SCHERING MEMBERS I'M ROBBIE
GONZALEZ NOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION. AND I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWO TWO AND
I'D LIKE TO A LINE ON MY
COMMENTS WITH. LEGAL AID AT
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
GET A LINE NUMBER SIXTY THREE
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
NINETY GALLAGHER WE ON THAT
BECAUSE YOU COORDINATE WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION. AS
WELL AS A WOMAN INCARCERATED
YOU FROM DJJ I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT Q.
THREE ON SIX FEBRUARY TWENTY
NINTH THERE HAS BEEN A THIRTY
SIX POINT 1% DECLINE THRALL
COUNTY INSIDE JUVENILE FACILITY
TO COPE WITH NINETEEN. ON
AVERAGE THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED
HOUSTON. AJ I BELIEVE THAT
WITH- THE SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
THREE AND OTHERS- WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY. CAN BE DONE THE
RIGHT WAY OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ARE NOT A NEW
BUREAUCRACY. THEY ARE THE MEANS
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE
SERVED IN THE COMMUNITY PATH ON
THE RIGHT COMMUNITY. INPUT AND-
HELLO. WITH WILL BE ESSENTIAL
MAKING THE AND GETTING IT DONE
RIGHT THANK YOU AND HAVE A GOOD
DAY. THANK YOU WOULD ALLOW
NUMBER EIGHT Y. EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS A- YEAH. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS MICHAEL. THAT THE EXACT
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION. SPEAKING
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT
FIFTEEN. THIRTY CAN. WE SUPPORT
INCLUSION OF LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL AUTHORIZING TRANSIT
AGENCIES. TO TEMPORARILY
APPLIED THEIR STATE OF GOOD
REPAIR PROGRAM FUN. AT THE
CARPETED- RESPONDING TO THE
PANDEMIC AND TO PREVENT FURTHER
TRANSIT SERVICE REDUCTION. IT'S
VITAL MEASURE RECOGNIZED THAT
THE PANDEMIC HAS CREATED A
COULD POTENTIAL FUNDING CRISIS
THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES
STATEWIDE. THAT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
OUR STATE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. INCLUDING LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
SPEAKER TRANSIT AGENCIES
REQUIRE STILL MORE FUNDING
RELIEF BUT THAT THAT IT IS AN
IMPORTANT AND APPRECIATED HER
STEP. WE URGE HER AYE VOTE ON
SB. EIGHT FIFTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE LINE NUMBER SIX
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M HERE CARE MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY THANK YOUNG ART SOLANO.
MERCED MENDOCINO CALIF OUR
HUMBLE AND NAPA ALL IN ALL
POSITIONS SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE. WE WISH THAT THERE ARE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WAS HOLD THIS
BILL THIS YEAR. THE WORKING
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE SO THAT
WHEN WE DO THIS WE DO IT RIGHT.
AFTER THOSE ARE. BY ASKING FOR
YOUR VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LITTLE AYE NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR NUMBER MY
NAME IS ANA HOW ABOUT A UNITED
BREAK OF CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE KELLY AGENCY
ADVOCACY COALITION MADE UP OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS LABOR
GROUP AND I GOT MY CLIPS
POVERTY FIGHTING ORGANIZATION
THAN OTHER TRUCKS THAT ARE
ENTHUSIASTIC THAT LOOK AT AT
THE EIGHT THREE ONE TO EXPAND
THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT. TO IMMIGRANT
WORKERS WE HAVE WORKED FOR
YEARS ON THE BUDGET PRIORITY.
WITH YOU ALL AND THANK YOU FOR
TAKING ACTION TODAY. THANK YOU
THE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX ONE TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI ANDREA SAN
MIGUEL ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATE OF
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT TO TWO OTHER ELITES
TO. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
AND EXPANDING JOB PROTECTED
FAMILY LEAVE FOR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. GIVE IT
A LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE ONE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MICHAEL BACK
ON BEHALF OF CHARGEPOINT IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTEEN SPECIFICALLY THE EEVEE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING AT THE
STATE UC THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO ONE THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND DILIGENCE AS AN
OPERATOR TO RECALL YOUR PLASTIC
ISSUE PREVENTION ORGANIZATIONS.
OVER 8290% OF THE FRANKENTHAL
PROBATION OFFICERS REGRETTABLY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP EIGHT
TWO THREE FOR. THE SECOND TIME
I WILL CONTINUE TO COMMISSION.
THANK YOU WILL GO ON NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE ONE
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS ROB GROWS
WALDRON HAPPENED CLEAN POWER
ALLIANCE. THE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATOR FOR THIRTY TWO
COMMUNITIES IN LOS ANGELES. AND
VENTURA COUNTY ONE EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL ONE ONE
FINE SPECIFICALLY SECTION
EIGHTEEN. AND THE FUNDS THAT
SUPPORT LECTURED VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
AT BC. NOT ONLY DO THE CHARGERS
DIRECTLY LEAD TO AN INCREASED
NUMBER OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
PARTLY IMPACT OUR STATE AIR
QUALITY. THE GREAT SHOVEL READY
JOBS AT A TIME WHEN PEOPLE ARE
DESPERATE LOOKING TO GET BACK
TO WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OVER THE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE ONE FOUR
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME A TRACKING
NUMBER YET FOUND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILIES
COALITION MADE STRONG SUPPORT
SB EIGHT TWENTY THAT PAID LEAVE
MEDIATION. TRAILER BILL THANK
YOU. GROWING NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS NICOLE LEE I'M
FROM URBAN PEACE MOVEMENT WERE-
A YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO CLOSE DJJ THE RIGHT WAY BY
SUPPORTING SB EIGHT TO THREE.
AFTER DECADES OF ABUSE WITHIN
THE STATE UNIT PRESIDENT SYSTEM
WE CAN'T TRANSFER THE PROBLEM
NOTHING CARBURETION FROM THE
STATE LEVEL TO PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS AROUND THE STATE
WITH NO OVERSIGHT WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT AND FLEXIBILITY. SO
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE CAN BE SERVED
IN WAYS THAT ACTUALLY CENTER
WHAT THEY NEED AND ALLOW THEM
TO BE SERVED LOCALLY AND IN THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE ONE FOUR THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
THE RELIEF KNOWING THAT I WITH
THE CHILDREN THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA. AS A MEMBER OF THE
COLLEGE. IF YOU CONDITION ARE
REPRESENTING OUR COLLECTION I
AM AT THE PORT OF AT EIGHT
THIRTY ONE AND FULL INCLUSION
OF THE KELLY AGENCY WE HAVE
BEEN ADVOCATING IN THE BIG CALL
IN THE CORRECT TAX. FILER
INCLUDING FOR TWO YEAR LONG
COLLUSION OF THE COUNT ET HE
HE IN THE- IN THE FEEDBACK IF
THE BEST GET NOW TO THE-
ECONOMIC RECOVERY APPARATUS.
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED
INVESTMENT FOR THE LONG TERM
THAT WILL PEOPLE GO CONCRETE
PROTECT ALL OF CALIFORNIA
WORKERS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
ADDRESS STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES
IN OUR TAX SYSTEM THAT CREEK DR
GREAT. INEQUITY FOR IMMIGRANT
WORKERS. AND THEIR FAMILIES
THANK YOU. WOULD ALLOW NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND- ONE. ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY MY NAME IS SARA
BACH I'M A MOTHER OF THREE
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN A SCHOOL
LEADER AND A MEMBER OF THE FUND
ALL KIDS COALITION. I AM
CALLING ON ON- SB EIGHT TWO
ZERO TODAY AND I APPRECATE THE
WORK TO ADJUST THE PREVIOUSLY
PASSED SB NINETY EIGHT TO FIND
SCHOOLS WITH PRO I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT TO FIX
THAT. FINDING WILL NOT BE
FOLLOWING ALL STUDENTS BUT THE
HOUSE PROJECT MADE STILL. TO
CHANGE HARM FAMILIES THAT ARE
SPEAKING ABOUT THE OPTION FOR
THEIR CHILDREN DURING THE
PANDEIC. BY NOT SERVING ALL
KIDS ARE OFF SCHOOL SERVING
THEM. FOR INSTANCE WITH RESPECT
TO THE NEW LANGUAGE THAT WILL
MANDATE THAT EITHER THE
PREVIOUSLY POPPED BUDGET BY THE
SCHOOL. ON OR BEFORE JUNE
THIRTIETH OR THE ENROLLMENT ON
OCTOBER SEVENTH WHICHEVER MUCH
WILL BE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS.
THAT SCHOOL BE FUNDED ON AND SO
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE A LOWER
BUDGET BECAUSE THEY WERE BEING.
PHYSICALLY CONSERVATIVE EARLIER
BUT A HIGHER NUMBER OF STUDENTS
ENROLLED ON THE SEVENTH. WILL.
NOT RECEIVE FUNDING FOR THEIR
STUDENTS. AS WELL THE STATE
DOES NOT THE- TO FAMILY. HAVE
DECIDED TO HOME SCHOOL. AND UP
THERE IT'S AN EQUITABLE THANK
YOU FOR MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. BUT
A LINE NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
SEVEN ZERO CHECK YOUR LINE FOR
SELF MUTE WE'RE HEARING AUDIO.
HEARING NO RESPONSE WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT IT'S ONE THREE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ENABLING AND THE THIRDBY
BANKRUPTCY SPECIALIST IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I SERVE
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
NAFTA. AND THAT'S NOT THAT BIG
ENOUGH CONSUMER BANKRUPTCY
ATTORNEYS. WITHOUT LIFE SUPPORT
SB EIGHT THIRTY TO INCREASING
THE HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION WE ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES WITH MANY
FAMILIES AND BUSINESS OWNERS
HAVE BEEN HIT HARD BY THE COBIT
TEN CAN DOWN NEXT. THEY ARE NOW
AT RISK OF LOSING THEIR HOMES
IN THIS CRISIS BECAUSE THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION IN
CALIFORNIA IS GROSSLY
INADEQUATE. WE SUPPORT SB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO PER THEIR FAMILY
STABILITY NEIGHBORHOOD
STABILITY AND ECONOMIC
STABILITY IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT MANY STATES HAVE UNLIMITED
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION. OR
EXEMPTIONS THAT EXCEED FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND
THEY HAVE A MUCH LOWER AVERAGE
HOME VALUE PRICE. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE A CLIENT WHO IS
SIXTY THREE YEARS OLD HER
HUSBAND WITH SIXTY SEVEN YEARS
OLD. THEY WERE RESTAURANT
OWNERS HIT BY A CODE RED. AT
THE HAVE BEEN POPPED AWAY THEY
WOULD HAVE HAD A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION. BUT WHEN
THE HOMESTEAD WHEN NOT AT HAVE
BEEN POPPED AWAY IT LEFT THE
WIFE. AT THE SIXTY THREE YEAR
OLD SINGLE PERSON WITH ONLY
ABOUT A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION SHE WILL
LOSE HER HOME. THE HOME THEY'VE
LIVED IN FOR THIRTY ONE YARDS
WITHOUT A FAIR INCREASE TO THE
HOMESTEAD. EXEMPTION THANK YOU.
WELL LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND SO ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR KURT CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
TWO THREE SB EIGHT TO FOUR S.
B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE AM EST
EIGHT THIRTY TWO THANK YOU.
WELL GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR ONE FOUR FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
TWENTY ACKLINS MAMA THREE AND
NINE CRAFTING BASED TECHNICAL
COMMUNITY LEADER FROM PLACENTIA
AND CALLING ABOUT SB EIGHT
COMPANIES ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
MAKE AMENDMENT TO PROVIDE CARE
FUNDING TO ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. INCLUDING THOSE AND
BILLING AND NON QUESTION BASED
TRICKLE THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO NINE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M GOOD.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT ONE
FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NUMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH
CORBIN AND KAISER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT THREE ONE THE BILL CAN
BECOME OTHER REQUESTED A BETTER
PROFIT LAST YEAR AND
APPROPRIATE THANK YOUNG. GO ON
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE ONE TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBER INTERCHANGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS WANT TO LOOK AT MYSELF
WITH THE OTHER COUNT YET THE
COALITION MEMBERS IF YOU GET
THE SUPPORT OF AB AT THE EIGHT
THREE ONE FIVE WELL I THINK
REGION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALBEIT BELIEVED SHOT ON BEHALF
OF BROADBAND TECHNOLOGY ECONOMY
AND THE PART OF THE FUNDING AND
COLLECTION EIGHTEEN OF THE ONE
ONE FIVE. WHICH WOULD GOING TO
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM. AT THE
PVC THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE ONE
FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROTH BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF VENTURA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT ONE FIVE
SIX. THREE THE PROVISIONS OF A
TO TRANSPORTATION FUNDING THANK
YOU. BUT A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR ONE FIVE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR CLIFF BURKE
WITH GOVERNMENTAL ADVOCATES IN
BEHALF OF SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
ONE EXPRESSED SUPPORT FIELD
WITH ELECTRICAL VEHICLE
PROVISION OF ONE ONE FIVE.
OPPOSITION TO S. . EIGHT TWO
THREE JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COLLECTORS. WANT TO EXPRESS
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
THREE TWO. THIS BILL WOULD
UNILATERALLY INCREASED THE
HOMEOWNER'S EXEMPTION
TRADITIONALLY THE ISSUE HAS
BEEN INTRODUCED IN POLICY
COMMITTEES AND DISCUSS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS NEGOTIATED TO A
REASONABLE INCREASE. THERE HAS
BEEN NO DISCUSSION NO
TRANSPARENCY NO INVOLVEMENT OF
INDUSTRY IN THIS LEGISLATION
WHICH APPEARED ON FRIDAY IT
INCREASES THE HOMEOWNER'S
EXEMPTION ALL THE WAY UP TO SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
CREATING A SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR EXEMPTION. WHICH EXCUSE
ME DOES NOT BENEFIT LOW INCOME
PEOPLE THE BENEFITS. HIGH
INCOME PEOPLE THE ADDICTION
BILL WAS MENTIONED EARLIER THAT
BILL WAS TIED TO THE COVETED
MERGING SEA DURING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROCLAMATION THIS
BILL IS A PERMANENT INCREASE.
IT IS IN NO WAY TIED TO COVERT
NINETEEN IT IS BEEN MARKETED AS
PART OF THE SENATE DEMOCRATS
ECONOMIC STIMULATION PROGRAM IN
REALITY WILL COST TO BUSINESS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AND THIS
VERY SAME BUSINESSES THAT
CREATE JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. IT
IS AN ANTI ECONOMIC STIMULUS
BILL IS A LOOPHOLE FOR THE RICH
IN THE APPLE WOULD YOUR OP. TO
THIS LAST MINUTE LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE ONE FIVE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN
GO ON BEHALF OF THE YOU'VE GOT
THE COLLISION THE CALIFORNIA
NINE THREE BIG NAMES OUT THERE
ARE YOU ALIVE THE BOYS MEN OF
COLOR. WE URGE YOU TO CLOSE THE
DAY DAY THE RIGHT WAY THE
FOURTEENTH ON A BILL EIGHT
TWENTY THREE. AFTER DECADES OF
ABUSE WITHIN THE STATE BUDGET
SYSTEM WE CANNOT TRANSFER YOU.
EQUALLY TROUBLED AND GET THE
COUNTY OF WITHOUT STATE
OVERSIGHT AND STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE REBATE
IT'S ABOUT THE ORGANIZATION.
PLEASE ENSURE THAT YOU CAN
FINALLY RECEIVE THE DEVELOPMENT
AND TRAUMA INFORMED CARE THEY
DESERVE I HAVE NEVER GOTTEN
COMPLETED STATE CORRECTIONS OR
LOCAL. PROBATION DEPARTMENTS.
THANK THANK YOU GROWING NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE IX
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS HEATHER SCOTT I AM A
CERTIFICATED TEACHER AND PARENT
OF TWO STUDENTS IN NON QUESTION
BE CHARTER I WANT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF SARA
BACH AND I WANT TO ASK YOU TO
AMEND SB EIGHT TWENTY TO FUND
ALL STUDENTS INCLUDING THOSE
WHO ATTEND NON QUESTION BE
CHARTERED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO ON OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE ONE THREE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM
ANGELINA SPICER- WITH THE PUSH
FOR COMMISSION. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WILL
BE CALIFORNIA'S WORKING
FAMILIES COALITION. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT TWO TWO.
THE PAID FAMILY MOVEMENT THE
DALLAS TRAILER BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GROWING NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE ONE
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTIAN
CRIPPLED PUBLIC COUNCIL
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT THIRTY TWO PROTECTING
HOMEOWNERS FROM FOR SALE OF
THEIR FAMILY HOMES- THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION WAS CREATED
TO PROTECT THE FAMILY HOME FROM
SALE BY UNSECURED CREDITOR IN
BANKRUPTCY CASES. I'M FORTUNATE
CALIFORNIA'S ALLOCTED
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION DENIES MANY
STRUGGLING HOMEOWNERS
PARTICULARLY SENIORS THE
PROTECTION OF OUR BANKRUPTCY
LAWS. SINCE THE MID NINETEEN
SEVENTIES OUR BANK OUR
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION HAS FAILED
TO KEEP PACE WITH THE- VALUE OF
HOMES AND EVER WIDENING GAP
THAT IS NEARLY TRIPLED IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS WE STRONGLY
URGE. THE SENATE TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF SB EIGHT THEIR TO.
SOCIALLY INCLINED CODE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL GET A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN ONE THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
RELATIVE MY NAME IS TINA
CARILLO ALLEN AND I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF FATHERS AND
FAMILIES OF SAN JOAQUIN IN
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS
WILL. BE WITH ALL THOSE WHO HAD
BEEN PART AND THE DJ DARK AND
SHAMEFUL HISTORY. OF WHICH MY
FATHER WAS ALSO A PRODUCT DOES.
NOT BRING UP THAT GENERATIONAL
NATURE. AND I'M CALLING TO URGE
YOU TO CLOSE THE DJJ THE RIGHT
WAY BY SUPPORTING. SB EIGHT Q.
THREE. AFTER GENERATIONS OF
ABUSE WITHIN THE STATE YOU
COULDN'T FIT THEM. WE CANNOT
TRANSFER YOU TO EQUALLY
TROUBLESOME AND IF YOU COULD
COUNTY SYSTEMS WITHOUT STATE
OVERSIGHT AND STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH COMMUNITY
BASED YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION WHO ARE WAITING
FOR OUR USE. PLEASE ENSURE THAT
YOU CAN FINALLY RECEIVE THE
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE. THEY DESERVE BUT
HAVE NEVER GOTTEN FROM OTHER
STATE CORRECTIONS. OR PROBATION
DEPARTMENT ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU CAN FIND. ON THE TAP.
THANK YOU GONNA GET A LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR ONE SIX
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN AND EVERYBODY ELSE
LISTENING I AM CALLING IN
REGARDS TO SB EIGHT TWENTY. I'M
CALLING TO ASK THAT IT BE
AMENDED TO APPLY FOR FAIR
FUNDING FOR ALL STUDENTS.
INCLUDING THOSE IN NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
MY NAME IS JANET GARDNER THANK
YOU. BUT A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO ONE SIX
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS PRETTY MARKARIAN AND I'M THE
PARENT OF THREE PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS. I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE
SB EIGHT TWENTY AND I PREPARE
AN EQUAL FUNDING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS INCLUDING DONCASTER
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL THANK YOU.
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE ONE SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARNIE SAN JOSE AND I
AM THE MOTHER OF THREE STUDENTS
AND A CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED
TEACHER A WORK AND A NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER. AND WE
ARE COMMITTED TO HAVING. TO
EDUCATE WITHOUT ANY FUNDING.
AND I KNOW OTHER. NON CRAFTING
THESE CHARTERS IN MY AREA WITH
THE SAME SITUATION. IN EARLY
OCTOBER NINTH. AT EIGHT TWENTY
BUT THEY'RE FAIR FUNDING FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE KNOWN
AND NOT THE STARTERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU WILL I NUMBER. ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVEN TWO
YOUR LINE A- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND YOUR AND WE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. WE
SUPPORT THE LANGUAGE AND SB
EIGHT ONE FIVE SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
REVISED TEMPORARY FLEXIBILITY
IN THE USE OF STATE TRANSIT
SYSTEMS BONDS THE SERVER CLEAN
THE STATE OF GOOD REPAIR
PROGRAM FUN. THAT'S WHERE I
VOTE ON THE MEASURE BUT BASIC.
THANK YOU WE'LL GET A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
ONE ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BRING A RESPONSE FROM ONE
FOURTEEN THAT DOES CONCLUDE OUR
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR. THAT WILL
CONCLUDE OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB SIX HEARING THANK YOU. THE
DRUG.